Rumor has it, new NHL hockey cards have arrived at Tim's, and every pack tells a story with rare finds, fan favorites, and exclusive prizes. Ready to score big? Start collecting today, only at Tim's, a participating in Canada for a limited time. I'm Jenna Fisher, and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together, and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate Office Lovers podcast just for you. Each week we will dive deep. into the world of the office with exclusive interviews behind-the-scenes details and lots of BFF stories. We're the Office Lady 6.0. Hi, lady. Hi there. Hello from Chicago still. Hello from my little closet at home. Everyone, I'm really excited about today's episode. We should tell you I'm still in Chicago. My play Ashland Avenue was extended to October 19th, but, But, woohoo, woohoo. Oh, thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Yes. Well, since I've been in Chicago,
听说蒂姆的店里来了新的 NHL 冰球星卡，每一包都藏着一个故事，里面有稀罕珍藏、粉丝至爱和独家奖品。准备好大展身手了吗？今天就开始收集吧，仅限蒂姆的店，加拿大参与门店限时供应。我是珍娜·费舍尔，我是安吉拉·金西。我们曾一起出演《办公室》，而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们要为你制作终极的“办公室”爱好者播客。每周我们都会深入探讨... 《办公室》的世界，有独家采访、幕后细节以及大量闺蜜故事。我们是“办公室女士”6.0。嗨，女士。嗨。来自芝加哥的问候，依然如此。来自我家小衣橱的问候。各位，我对今天的单集非常兴奋。我们应该告诉你，我还留在芝加哥。我的话剧《阿什兰大道》延期到了10月19日，但是，但是，呜呼，呜呼。哦，谢谢。谢谢。谢谢。是的。好吧，自从我来到芝加哥以来，
Angela, you and Cassie have put together an amazing episode today, diving into email surveillance, Michael's improv class, and your love of improv. Will you tell everybody what we're doing today? Yes, I am so excited about this episode because Cassie and I are huge improv nerds. Tell us your background with improv. A lot of you guys listening might know that my early days as a performer. I was doing tons of shows at IOS. I performed every chance I could get. I was just getting up on stage all the time. And Cassie shares my passion for improv. And I'm so tickled by it. Cassie, can you hop on and tell us a little bit about your improv journey? Yeah, of course. Yeah, I'm a huge improv nerd. And I took my first improv class at 14 at a community college with a friend. His dad would literally like drop us off at this community college and we'd be doing improv with what I perceived at the time. the oldest people in the world who were actually, like, probably 20. Yeah. And then, yeah, I just kept doing it throughout college.
安吉拉，你和卡西今天准备了一集精彩绝伦的节目，深入探讨了邮件监控、迈克尔的即兴表演课以及你对即兴表演的热爱。你愿意告诉大家我们今天要做什么吗？是的，我对这一集超级兴奋，因为我和卡西都是十足的即兴表演迷。跟我们聊聊你的即兴表演背景吧。收听节目的很多朋友可能都知道，我早期作为表演者的时候。我做过大量在 IOS 的演出。只要有机会我都会去表演。我就是一直在舞台上不断练习。卡西也和我一样对即兴表演充满热情。我对此感到非常高兴。卡西，你能上线跟我们聊聊你的即兴表演之旅吗？好，当然。好，我是一个超级即兴表演迷。我在 14 岁时和朋友在一个社区学院上了第一堂即兴表演课。他的爸爸简直就像是把我们送到这个社区学院，然后我们就和那些在我当时看来，可以说是世界上最老的人一起做即兴表演，而他们其实可能也就 20 岁左右。是啊。然后，是的，我在整个大学期间都一直在坚持。
And then when I moved to L.A., I started taking classes at UCB and got on Harold night. And, yeah, I'm just a huge improv nerd. You know, I had said this when you and I were working on this, but, like, I feel like Cassie is my younger self in some ways when it comes to the improv scene because I took improv in junior high. That's awesome. And I was like, I just loved it. from the get-go. I had an amazing theater teacher that did improv with us. And then again,
然后当我搬到洛杉矶时，我开始在 UCB 上课，并进入了海罗尔之夜。然后，是的，我只是一个超级即兴表演迷。你知道的，当你我一起筹备这个的时候我说过，但就像是，我觉得卡西在某些方面就是年轻时的我，说到即兴表演圈的话，因为我在初中就学过即兴表演。那太棒了。然后我就觉得，我从一开始就爱上它了。我有一位超棒的戏剧老师，带着我们做即兴表演。然后再次，
came to L.A., did I.O. And Cassie actually invited me to come to UCB, and I did ASCAT one night. You have to explain what ASCAT is for people outside of the improv community. Right. I do feel like we get a little insider improv-y together, Cassie, when we start with your improv lingo. I know. I just could hear Rain Wilson somewhere in the world making fun of me right now. Yeah, so Askat, and they also did this at Improv Olympic 2, it was called Armando Diaz. You get a suggestion from the audience, and then there's a monologist who does a monologue on the spot, a true life story, not scripted, just whatever they thought of from that suggestion. And then in the wings are the improvisers. They're listening to that information, and they're going to deconstruct it and use it to inspire a series of scenes and runners in its long form.
来到洛杉矶，去了 I.O.。卡西甚至邀请我去 UCB，我参加了一个晚上的 ASCAT。你得为即兴表演圈外的人解释一下什么是 ASCAT。对的。我觉得我们在一起时，一聊起你的即兴表演黑话，就会变得有点业内即兴的感觉，卡西。我知道。我简直能听到雷恩·威尔逊在世界的某个地方笑话我呢。对的，所以 Askat，他们还在即兴奥林匹克 2 馆做过这个，叫做阿曼多·迪亚斯。你从观众那里得到一个建议，然后有一个独白者当场做一段独白，一个真实的生活故事，没有剧本，只是根据那个建议想到了什么就说什么。然后侧幕条那边是即兴演员。他们听着那些信息，然后将其解构并用来激发一系列的长篇场景和主线。
And it was so much fun. a blast. You know, I've done that. Yeah. Oh, awesome. I was a monologist. I was one of the people who came and got a suggestion from the audience and I told a real life story. And then I watched the improvisers bring it to life. It's so cool. If you live in a city where you can go see a show like this, it is a really fun night out. It's so fun. And when I was on the office, I would hit up the entire cast to come and be the monologist. And I'll never forget the night Creed did it. Because he did the thing that Creed does where you're like, wait, Creed, wait, come on, is that story? But you just had to go with it, right?
这太有趣了。太好玩了。你知道的，我做过那个。太棒了。我是独白者。我是那些过来从观众那里得到建议并讲述真实生活故事的人之一。然后我看着即兴演员们把它演绎得生动活泼。这太酷了。如果你住在一个能去看这种演出的城市，那真是一个非常有趣的夜晚。太有趣了。当我在《办公室》的时候，我会联系整个剧组来当独白者。我永远不会忘记克里德做的那天晚上。因为他做了克里德会做的那种事，让你觉得，等等，克里德，等等，拜托，那是真的故事吗？但你只能顺着他来，对吧？
Like, what is real? What is not? Well, you guys know, I don't talk about this a lot. Angela, I don't even know if you know this as my BFF. What? You know, I did improv in L.A. What? What?
比如，什么是真的？什么不是？好吧，你们知道的，我不常谈这个。安吉拉，我甚至不知道你作为我最好的朋友是否知道这一点。什么？你知道的，我在洛杉矶做过即兴表演。什么？什么？
What? Oh, my gosh. I did. How did we not know this? For like almost two. Because I was, I was terrible. I took improv classes at a small studio in Van Nuys, California, and I did it because my agent at the time, he looked at my resume and he said, you have such wonderful training, you've got no improv training.
什么？哦，天哪。我做过。我们怎么会不知道呢？差不多两年。因为我，我太差劲了。我在加利福尼亚州范奈司的一个小工作室上了即兴表演课，我这么做是因为我当时的经纪人，他看了我的简历，然后他说，你有这么棒的训练，你可一点即兴表演训练都没有。
And, you know, studios, producers, directors, they like to see that. It's the thing right now. You need to get that. So I said, okay. And I went and I trained. So I know all your references. I know yes and I know all the things. I'm not good. I did a few shows. It was like anyone who saw me in those shows will tell you I'm just not good. Here's what I'm good at. Here's what I'm very good at. If I develop a character over time and I know that character, I can improvise as that character. What I can't do is in third, 30 seconds or five seconds, come up with something interesting to say or invent a character right on the spot. Like, I need my time. I need my long runway. Right, right. But I love improv. I love it. Well, I think you're so good, you know, improvising as Pam, my God, and I've seen you do
而且，你知道的，工作室、制片人、导演，他们喜欢看到这一点。这是现在的潮流。你需要有这个。所以我说，好吧。然后我就去训练了。所以我知道你所有的参考梗。我知道“是的，而且”，我知道所有这些。我不太行。我做过几次演出。就像任何看过我那些演出的人都会告诉我，我就是不行。这是我擅长的。这是我非常擅长的。如果我随着时间推移开发了一个角色并且我很了解那个角色，我可以作为那个角色进行即兴表演。我做不到的是在 30 秒或 5 秒内，想出有趣的话来或者当场凭空创造一个角色。比如，我需要时间。我需要长长的助跑期。对，对。但我喜欢即兴表演。我爱死它了。好吧，我觉得你真的很棒，你知道的，作为帕姆进行即兴表演，天哪，而且我也看过你做过...
other work too, and it's so natural for you to know your character's voice. But I think, yeah, with improv the minute you're on a stage, you have to make choices very quickly and just really be terrible. They were terrible and fumbly and weird. Even just naming my character. You have to come up with a name on the spot. Yeah. My names would be like, I'm Margaret Momenschimblur. Like suddenly my words didn't work. It was crazy. I just still can't believe you took an improv class and as your BFF. I've never known that. For two years, lady. For two years. Yeah. I'm going to have to process that. I don't know. You're like an onion. I just, there, there's layers to you. I don't know after all these years. Well, listen, everyone, today for Office Lady 6.0, we have a lot of fun stuff. First of all,
其他的工作也是如此，你知道你角色的声音对你来说是那么自然。但我觉得，是的，在即兴表演中，一旦你上了舞台，你就必须非常迅速地做出选择，然后表现得真的很糟糕。它们糟糕、笨拙而且诡异。甚至只是给我的角色起个名字。你必须当场想出一个名字。是的。我的名字会像是，我是玛格丽特·莫门辛布勒。就好像突然之间我的词汇不管用了。这太疯狂了。我还是无法相信你上过即兴表演课，而作为你最好的闺蜜。我从来都不知道。整整两年，女士。整整两年。好吧。我得消化一下这个。我不知道。你就像个洋葱。我只是，你身上还有层层叠叠的秘密。过了这么多年我都不知道。好吧，听着，各位，今天在“办公室女士”6.0，我们有很多有趣的内容。首先，
we watched the superfan version of email surveillance from season two. Yes, there are 13 extra minutes of footage, and we are going to cover all of the extra scenes in the improv storyline specifically. And then I talked to Michael Norton. He came in the studio. He plays Michael Scott. improv teacher. He shares with us what it was like to be in those scenes with Steve Carell. And then Cassie and I thought, what a better way to end this episode than with a little improv. So she invited some of her friends from UCB and we do a little improv set. It's very fun. I loved it. Well, listen, let's start by talking about email surveillance. I loved rewatching this episode. There's so many great runners in this. We're going to talk about Michael's improv, but rewatching it,
我们观看了第二季《邮件监控》的超级粉丝版本。是的，有 13 分钟的额外镜头，我们将专门涵盖即兴表演剧情线中的所有额外场景。然后我采访了迈克尔·诺顿。他来到了录音室。他饰演迈克尔·斯科特的即兴表演老师。他跟我们分享了与史蒂夫·卡瑞尔一起拍摄那些场景的感受。然后卡西和我认为，用一点即兴表演来结束这一集再合适不过了。所以她邀请了她在 UCB 的一些朋友，我们做了一小段即兴表演。非常有趣。我很喜欢。好吧，听着，我们先来聊聊《邮件监控》。我太喜欢重温这一集了。这里面有这么多精彩的主线。我们要聊聊迈克尔的即兴表演，但重温之后，
Jim's party. I forgot so much of it, lady. It was so funny. Well, there's a lot of classic moments. I mean, this is when Pam gets her tour of Jim's bedroom. And there's more of that in the superfan. Yep. But I found something that I didn't realize was in this episode. Do you remember when we did all about Michael Scott and I talked about my love of Michael's mangled words? Yes. Well, I missed one. The first time we watched email surveillance, I have to share it. It's in a Michael talking head. It's in both. the original and the superfan version, Michael is realizing he has not been invited to Jim's party, and he's trying to process that. And he drops a really great mangled word. So add this one to the list if you're keeping track. Okay. Let's hear it. There's always a distance between
吉姆的派对。我忘了很多内容，女士。太搞笑了。嗯，有很多经典的时刻。我的意思是，这就是帕姆参观吉姆卧室的时候。超级粉丝版里有更多这方面的内容。是的。但我发现了一些我以前没意识到在这一集里的东西。你还记得我们做关于迈克尔·斯科特的所有内容时，我谈到我有多喜欢迈克尔那些乱七八糟的话吗？记得。嗯，我漏掉了一个。我们第一次看《邮件监控》时，我必须分享出来。它在一个迈克尔的单人访谈里。在原版和超级粉丝版里都有，迈克尔意识到他没有被邀请去吉姆的派对，他正在努力接受这件事。然后他说了一句非常精彩的混乱语句。所以如果你在做记录，把这个也加到名单里。好吧。说来听听。总是有距离...
a boss and the employees. It is just nature's rule. It's intimidation, mostly. It's the awareness that they are not me. You see, they're thinking, wow, Michael Scott, I really respect him. What will I do if I drop spinach dip on him at a party? What is he going to think of me? What? Is it going to affect my salary? Ooh, Michael Scott. I don't know. I don't know. I do think that I am very approachable as one of the guys, but maybe I need to be even approachable. Yeah. And while he's trying to be more approachable or he's just walking around messing with everyone's stuff with that little puppet thing. Yeah, he's annoying people. He's definitely not being more approachable or are. Well, I have a background catch for you that I just became fixated on.
老板和员工之间。这是大自然的规则。这主要是威慑。这是一种觉悟，即他们不是我。你看，他们在想，哇，迈克尔·斯科特，我真的很尊重他。如果我在派对上把菠菜酱洒在他身上，我会怎么样？他会怎么看我？什么？这会影响我的薪水吗？哦，迈克尔·斯科特。我不知道。我不知道。我确实认为我很平易近人，就像他们中的一员一样，但也许我需要变得更加平易近人。是的。当他试图变得更平易近人，或者他只是四处走动，拿着那个小木偶摆弄每个人的东西时。是的，他在惹恼大家。他绝对没有变得更平易近人。好吧，我有一个背景彩蛋要告诉你，我对此着迷了。
It's like an old school background catch lady. If I still did note cards, I would have written this on a note card. What is it? I would have written white cardigan with blue teddy bears all over. it? What the heck, Meredith? Because Meredith is wearing a sweater that I don't remember. It's like a cardigan. It's got all these really cutesy blue teddy bears on it. She looks like a kindergarten teacher. Go to 13 minutes, 42 seconds. What is the sweater? I don't think we ever see it again. I love an old-fashioned background catch from you, Angela. I couldn't stop looking at it. Lady, can I talk for a second about this article that you wrote about all of your food and all of your eating?
这就像是一个老派的背景彩蛋，女士。如果我还用记事卡的话，我就会把这个写在记事卡上。是什么？我会写：到处都是蓝泰迪熊的白色开衫。这怎么回事，梅瑞狄斯？因为梅瑞狄斯穿着一件我不记得的毛衣。就像一件开衫。上面有所有这些非常可爱的蓝色泰迪熊。她看起来像个幼儿园老师。转到 13 分钟 42 秒。这是什么毛衣？我觉得我们再也没见过它了。我喜欢你挖掘的老式背景彩蛋，安吉拉。我简直移不开眼。女士，我能说一会儿你写的关于你所有的食物和饮食的文章吗？
Yes, I guess. Because the same charm of you noticing this weird sweater on Meredith and pointing it out is just all throughout this article of your food eating. It was like, tell people what it is. It's like a food diary that you wrote. Okay, so here's the thing. For Josh and I's cookbook, you can make this. doing a lot of press. And I was approached by New York Magazine to do a section they
好吧，我想是的。因为你注意到梅瑞狄斯这件奇怪的毛衣并把它指出来的这种魅力，在你的关于吃东西的文章里随处可见。这就好像是，告诉大家这是什么。这就像是你写的一份食物日记。好吧，所以事情是这样的。为了我和乔希的食谱书，你可以做这个。进行了很多宣传。我被《纽约杂志》接洽，要求做一个他们...
called Grub Street Diet where you just for five days journal about your food, where you eat it, like stories behind your food, basically. And a lot of people have done it. Jesse Tyler Ferguson, Sarah Jessica Parker. I mean, so many, the list of people that have done it was so interesting to me. And yeah, I spent a week journaling about my food. And I sent it to Jenna. And I was like, I feel like I'm so boring. Does this sound okay? It's not boring, everybody. It was riveting. I was on the edge of my seat. If you like Angela's journals in general and then you like food and hearing descriptions of food, you're going to love this. Angel, you have to, when this is out, you have to link to it. It's like one of the best things I've read all year. You're so cute, lady. But thank you. I will. I loved it. And I'm realizing now that one of the reasons is because of your love of detail, like with these background catches. Okay, everybody, you have to read this food journal. Or maybe after it comes out, we're going to need to do a Friday chitchat where you
称为“格鲁布街饮食”的专栏，你只需连续五天记录你的食物日记，你在哪里吃，比如你的食物背后的故事，基本上就是这样。很多人都做过。杰西·泰勒·弗格森，莎拉·杰西卡·帕克。我的意思是，太多人了，做过的人的名单让我觉得太有趣了。是的，我花了一个星期记录我的食物日记。我把它发给了珍娜。我说，我觉得我太无聊了。这听起来还好吗？一点也不无聊，各位。这太引人入胜了。我当时看得全神贯注。如果你总的来说喜欢安吉拉的日记，然后你又喜欢食物和听到对食物的描述，你会爱死这个的。安吉拉，当这个发布的时候，你一定要放个链接。这简直是我今年读过的最好的东西之一。你太可爱了，女士。不过谢谢你。我会的。我很喜欢。我现在意识到原因之一是因为你对细节的热爱，就像这些背景彩蛋一样。好了，各位，你们一定要读这篇食物日记。或者也许在它发布之后，我们需要做一个周五闲聊，届时你...
read some of it as well. Please, I'm begging. Oh my gosh, me and journals, you guys. I just, I mean, I love it. All right. Well, now let's dive into the improv portion of this episode. So if you remember, Michael has an improv class. It's the same night as Jim's party, which he was not invited to. He is bummed. He wants to bail on his class. If Jim would only invite him to the party, he would bail on this improv class. Oh, in a second. That he loves. But that never happens. So Michael's heading into his improv class. He's feeling a little blue. When we did our second drink of this episode, I talked about how there were so many extra scenes from the storyline that didn't make it in. There really are. There's so many. For starters, Michael has a talking head before he goes to
也会读一些内容。求你了，我求你了。哦，天哪，我和日记，你们这些家伙。我只是，我的意思是，我太喜欢了。好吧。现在，让我们深入探讨这一集的即兴表演部分。所以如果你们还记得，迈克尔有一个即兴表演班。这和吉姆的派对是同一天晚上，而他没有被邀请。他很沮丧。他想跳过他的课。如果吉姆只邀请他去派对，他就会翘掉这个即兴表演课。哦，马上。他很喜欢的课。但那从来没有发生。所以迈克尔正前往他的即兴表演课。他感觉有点沮丧。当我们为这一集制作第二杯饮品时，我谈到了为什么有那么多没有被采用的剧情线的额外场景。真的有很多。有太多了。首先，迈克尔在去...
improv class where he shares just a little bit about what you can expect from his improv style. This is a talking head that was deleted. It's now in the superfan version. You got to hear it. Five o'clock. Time to go get my improv on. A little bit of the comedy juice. Mm. All right. See if you can guess what this is. That is a dinosaur, getting ready to go to improv class. Just a taste of the improv. Just a little sneak peek. I mean, it just sounds awful.
即兴表演班之前有一个单人访谈，他在其中简短地分享了你可以对他的即兴表演风格有什么样的期待。这是一个被删减的单人访谈。现在它在超级粉丝版本里。你得听听看。五点钟。是时候去搞我的即兴表演了。来点喜剧果汁。嗯。好了。看看你能不能猜出这是什么。那是一只恐龙，正准备去上即兴表演课。这只是即兴表演的一点滋味。只是一点点偷窥。我的意思是，听起来太糟糕了。
And I want to let you guys know that if you watch it, it is also awful to see. It's not good. It's not good. It's like, what is he going to bring to the stage? Angela, Cassie, have you guys ever had to do improv scenes where you were an animal? Was it ever suggested that you be some sort of animal? Yeah. Yeah. Yes. Both of you? Is that pretty common? In my two years of improv, I guess I never had to do this. I mean, we did it as an exercise. Cassie, you go first.
我想告诉大家的是，如果你看了它，看起来也一样糟糕。这可不好。这可不好。这就好比，他到底要在舞台上展现什么？安吉拉，卡西，你们有没有做过扮演动物的即兴表演场景？有没有人建议过你们去扮演某种动物？有。有。有。你们两个都有？这很常见吗？在我两年的即兴表演中，我想我从来没遇到过这种情况。我的意思是，我们把它作为一种练习。卡西，你先说。
Recently, I've been in shows where I played either a horse or a cow. So I guess, my team really liked farm animals. But, you know, we get in and out. It's not like 20 minutes of just animal work. I had an improv class one time where you would get two suggestions and then have to just start a scene. And I remember it because it was so bad. So it became like a core memory for me. Our suggestions were penguins delivering a refrigerator. That's funny to me. Yeah. That suggestion is funny. The execution didn't go well. We had low penguin arms, and I think we got really, my scene partner and I, this was early in my improv classes. We got really caught up in how would these penguins be able to lift something?
最近，我参演的剧里，我演过马或者牛。所以我想，我的团队真的很喜欢农场动物。但是，你知道的，我们演完就下场。这可不是那种持续 20 分钟纯动物表演。我有一次上即兴表演课，你得到两个提示，然后就必须直接开始一个场景。我记得很清楚，因为当时太糟糕了。所以它对我来说就像是一个核心记忆。我们的提示是企鹅递送一台冰箱。我觉得这挺搞笑的。是的。这个提示很好笑。执行得不太顺利。我们当时把企鹅的翅膀垂得很低，我觉得我和我的搭档真的陷入了——这是我早期上即兴表演课的时候——我们真的很纠结这些企鹅到底怎么才能举起什么东西？
Aw. You got too practical and literal. We got too literal instead of just playing out a scene. We were just like trying to bat at a refrigerator. It was horrible. It was horrible. Aw. Anyway, okay, that's hilarious, Cassie.
啊。你们变得太注重实用和字面意思了。我们变得太拘泥于字面意思，而不是仅仅去演好一个场景。我们只是试图去拍打一台冰箱。太糟糕了。太糟糕了。啊。不管怎样，好吧，太搞笑啦，卡西。
So Michael arrives to his improv class, and we learn very quickly that he has the same bit that he does in every single scene. Yes. He just plays a version of Michael Scarn. He pulls out a gun, and he just shoots everyone in the scene every time so quickly. So then he's the only person left on stage. And there is a scene in the superfan version where the improv teacher, played by Michael Notton, is fed. up and he's just over it we talk a little bit about this with michael not in the studio but i wanted you to hear the scene okay you can't just shoot everyone in the scene well if you hadn't stopped the scene you were seeing where it was going okay what about the scene they set up boring no it wasn't no more guns no no michael want you give me all the guns you have just get rid of all your guns and give them to me great okay okay
然后迈克尔到达了他的即兴表演课，我们很快了解到他在每一个场景里用的都是同一个梗。是的。他只是扮演麦克·斯坎的一个版本。他掏出一枪，每次都那么快地把场景里的每个人都给枪毙了。所以最后舞台上只剩下他一个人。在超级粉丝版本里有一个场景，由迈克尔·诺顿饰演的即兴表演老师，已经受够了...
it's amazing because then he pantomimes handing over all of his guns and it's like his imaginary guns yeah it's very funny actually it's very funny and michael is so bratty like at the end he's just like he's such he's such a pill in this class so i went back to our table draft lady because i was curious how some of these improv scenes started and i wanted to share two things I found, okay? Okay. One describes the improv teacher. And here's what it says. The teacher, Chris, late 20s, actually enjoys this job. He's nice, supportive. Hmm. And then I found a talking head for the improv teacher, Chris, and one for Michael in response, they would have aired back to back. Here's what they said. Interior classroom. Chris says, okay, now let's all review the
他真的受够了，我们和在录音室的迈克尔·诺顿稍微聊了聊这个，但我想让你听听这个场景。好的，你不能只是把场景里的每个人都枪毙了。好吧，如果你没有打断场景的话，你本来能看到它会走向何方的。好吧，刚才那个布景的场景呢？很无聊。不，才不无聊。不要再拿枪了。不，不，迈克尔，把你身上所有的枪都交出来，把你的枪统统扔掉，全都给我。好，好吧，好吧。
the basic rule of yes and, you say yes to what your partners have set up and then you add onto it. Immediately it cuts to a Michael talking head. Michael says, what I do is, yes, I see what you're doing. And here's something better. That's where you get the gold. Chris is trying his best, but he's an improv instructor in Scranton. If he was really talented, he'd be an improv instructor in Hollywood. That's amazing. That is amazing. I know.
这太神奇了，因为接着他做手势交出了他所有的枪，就像是他的想象中的枪一样。是的，非常搞笑，实际上非常搞笑。而且迈克尔真的很任性——最后他就好像，他在这个班里简直是个讨厌鬼。所以我回到了我们的桌面剧本草案，女士，因为我很好奇其中一些即兴表演场景是如何开始的，我想分享我发现的两件事，好吗？好。其中一个描述了即兴表演老师。上面是这么写的：老师，克里斯，20多岁，其实很享受这份工作。他人很好，很支持大家。嗯。然后我找到了一个即兴表演老师克里斯的单人访谈，还有一个迈克尔作为回应的单人访谈，它们本来应该背靠背播出的。它们是这样说的。室内，教室。克里斯说，好，现在让我们一起来复习一下...
Lady, if my memory serves, doesn't the script also say that everyone in the class is in their 20s except for Michael and the one woman Mary Beth, who is like around his same age? Yeah. And I just because I remember that, like, I have, I remember thinking that was such a funny detail when we were doing the table read. But also, I love how every time Mary Beth would get picked to be Michael's scene partner, he just rolls his eyes. Like, she clearly drives him nuts. Oh, she bothers him so much.
“是的，而且”的基本规则，你对同伴设定好的内容说“是的”，然后在此基础上添枝加叶。立刻切到了迈克尔的单人访谈。迈克尔说，我做的是，是的，我看到你在做什么了。这里有个更好的点子。这才是能挖到金子的地方。克里斯尽力了，但他只是斯克兰顿的一个即兴表演教练。如果他真的很有才华，他就会去好莱坞当即兴表演教练了。这太棒了。这太绝了。我知道。
And do you remember the scene where she starts as like a little girl licking a lollipop and Michael can't stand it? So he just comes in and he Michael scorns her. Yeah, immediately. And then the two of them, Mary Beth and Michael, actually, end up getting in this little like squabble right they're like fighting and going back and forth at each other and there's so much more of it in the deleted scenes only a little bit made it into the super fan episode because there was so much i looked it up in the script and a lot of this moment is improvised the mary beth michael just like snotty back and forth their argument
女士，如果我的记忆没出错的话，剧本里是不是还写着班里的每个人都在 20 多岁，除了迈克尔和那个跟她差不多大年纪的女人玛丽·贝丝？是的。而且我只是因为我记得这个，就像是，我记得我们在围读剧本时觉得这是一个非常搞笑的细节。而且我也喜欢每次玛丽·贝丝被选为迈克尔的场景搭档时，他就会直翻白眼。就像是，她显然把他快逼疯了。哦，她太烦他了。
yeah their argument and i also talked to michael not and about it but i want you to hear it She was kind of tripping me up. Because she was, I was trying to get something going when I was over her with the gun. And then she kept like changing the story. He was saying, well, you kept going into like nuclear or something. It's like that's not where the scene was going. It goes wherever. Well, it goes in the best direction.
你还记得那个场景吗，她一开始像个小女孩一样舔着棒棒糖，而迈克尔实在受不了了？所以他直接走过去，用麦克·斯坎的方式对付她。是的，立刻。然后他们两个，玛丽·贝丝和迈克尔，实际上最后陷入了这种小小的争吵，对吧？他们就像是在吵架，你来我往地互怼，被删减的场景里有更多这样的内容，只有一小部分进入了超级粉丝单人剧集，因为内容实在太多了。我在剧本里查过了，这一幕的很多内容都是即兴发挥的，玛丽·贝丝和迈克尔那种刻薄的你来我往的争吵...
And that was not the best direction. And I felt like he was ordering me around because he, he... Well, I might get me... That character orders people around. And that's, you should have just gone. All your characters order people around, though, and there's stronger choices. I don't think there's any stronger choice
是的，他们的争吵，而且我也和迈克尔·诺顿聊过这个，但我想让你听听。她有点把我搞糊涂了。因为她，当我拿着枪压在她上方时，我正试图让事情运转起来。然后她一直像是在改变故事。他说，嗯，你一直在扯到核武器什么的。就好像那根本不是场景发展的方向。它会去往任何地方。好吧，它会朝最好的方向发展。
than being a really strong character. We've seen you do that character before, though. I mean, you know, that's cool. Well, it's talk, you know, when you refine it, you refine a character down to its essence. Like Jim Carrey or something, sure. Exactly, thank you. Right.
而那不是最好的方向。我觉得他在对我指手画脚，因为他...好吧，我可能让我...那个角色就是会对别人指手画脚。那是，你本来应该直接顺着演的。不过你所有的角色都会对别人指手画脚，而且有更强烈的选择。我不认为有什么选择比成为一个真正强大的角色更强烈。不过我们以前看你演过那个角色。我的意思是，你知道的，那挺酷的。好吧，这可以说是，你知道的，当你把它精炼的时候，你把一个角色精炼到了它的精髓。就像吉姆·凯瑞或者别的什么，当然。没错，谢谢。对。
Well, I wasn't saying you. I appreciate that. I know. Let's just try another one. That is very nice. I just... Or Ryan Stiles, something like... Yeah, I just, you know,
好吧，我没说你。我很感激。我知道。我们再试一个吧。那真是太好了。我只是...或者瑞安·斯泰尔斯，类似...对，我只是，你知道的，
you just maybe get on the ground. I don't feel that safe in the scene. You shouldn't have been, because you were dealing with Michael Scar. That was exactly what I was hoping to achieve. So that is probably the best thing you could have... That's a compliment. He's excited.
你可能只要趴到地上就行。我在这个场景里感觉很不安全。你不该觉得安全，因为你在和麦克·斯坎打交道。这正是我希望达到的效果。所以这可能是你能做出的最好的...这是一个赞美。他很兴奋。
Thank you. I mean, it's... good. That is great improv right there. That's an example of amazing improv. And I love how unteachable Michael is. He is the most unteachable student. Yeah. I can't believe out of that whole conversation, he found a compliment in it about his improv style. I have to add one other detail that I love so much about this when I read the shooting draft. It's that the improv class is at the Scranton High School. Yes. And it's just like a little detail that I just love. love that they're like in a classroom, like after hours. Anyway.
谢谢。我的意思是，这...很好。这才是真正的棒极了的即兴表演。这就是精彩即兴表演的一个例子。而且我喜欢迈克尔那种无可救药的特质。他绝对是最不可教的学生。是的。我简直不敢相信在整场对话中，他竟然能在其中找到一句关于他即兴表演风格的赞美。我必须补充另一个细节，当我阅读拍摄剧本时，我对这个细节喜爱至极。那就是即兴表演课是在斯克兰顿高中上。是的。这就像是一个小小的细节，我就是喜欢他们像是在一间教室里，就像是课后一样。不管怎样。
Well, Michael has a final talking head at the end of his improv class that is in the superfan episode. It might explain even further how annoying he is to the other students. I think we should hear it. Improv's hit or miss. Last week, I was on fire. It was just Robin Williams, Ali G. Ryan Stiles nailing it. Home runs every swing of the bat. this week I was paired up with some pretty lame people so you have to deal with that
好吧，迈克尔在他的即兴表演课结束时有一个最后的单人访谈，它在超级粉丝单人剧集中。它可能进一步解释了他对其他学生来说有多么烦人。我觉得我们应该听听。即兴表演时好时坏。上周，我状态火热。简直就是罗宾·威廉姆斯、阿里·G、瑞安·斯泰尔斯在巅峰发挥。每次挥棒都击出全垒打。本周我和一些相当蹩脚的人搭档，所以你必须应付那些人...
whose line is it anyway it's Michael Scott's line because generally Michael Scott's is the funniest line he thinks he's the bee's knees I mean I really really I know I've said this before but I would have loved to see this as a runner
谁是线索？这是迈克尔·斯科特的台词，因为通常迈克尔·斯科特的台词是最搞笑的，他认为自己了不起极了。我的意思是，我真的很，我知道我以前说过这话，但我真的很想看到这成为一条常驻主线。
I would have loved to have Michael's improv class come back I would have loved for him maybe to have one time invite Dwight to go with him Oh, so rich. There's so much there. I really wish that would have happened. But, okay, there is one more scene in the shooting draft from this episode that I wanted to share with you. You can watch it in the superfan version, but I wanted to read you the stage direction because it really paints the picture.
我很希望迈克尔的即兴表演课能再次回归。我真的很希望他有一次能邀请德 Dwight 和他一起去。哦，太丰富了。里面有太多内容了。我真的很希望那能发生。但是，好吧，这一集的拍摄剧本里还有一个场景我想和你们分享。你可以在超级粉丝版本里看到它，但我很想读一下舞台指导，因为它真的把画面勾勒出来了。
And it kind of made me a little sad for Michael. It's that thing where you're like he's being such a turd and now I feel bad for him. All right, Interior High School hallway, everyone is heading out quickly in a group. Michael rushes to catch up to them. As he nears them, he hears this. Mary Beth says, How do I get to Bernie's tavern from here? Bill says, don't worry, we're going to carpal. Michael's look shows he doesn't know about this.
这让我对迈克尔有点同情。就是那种感觉，你会觉得他太混蛋了，但现在我又为他感到难过。好了，室内，高中走廊，每个人都在成群结队地快步离开。迈克尔赶忙去追上他们。当他靠近他们时，他听到了这样的话。玛丽·贝丝说，从这里怎么去伯尼酒馆？比尔说，别担心，我们拼车。迈克尔的表情表明他对此一无所知。
Michael to the group, hey, I'd love to meet up with you all at Bernice, but I have a party to go to. Big work party. Can't get out of it. A few people turn and give Michael polite smiles and keep walking. Oh, there's two parties he wasn't invited to. I know, and they're rushing out.
迈克尔对大家说，嘿，我很乐意去伯尼酒馆和大家碰面，但我有个派对要去。一个非常重要的工作派对。推不掉。几个人转过身，对迈克尔礼貌地笑了笑，然后继续往前走。哦，有两个他没被邀请去的派对。我知道，而且他们都在急匆匆地离开。
They don't want him to catch up with him. It's just, I was like, oh, Michael. Well, I loved getting to revisit all of that extra footage from Michael's improv. That was a lot of fun. And next up, we get to hear from Michael Norton, the actor who played Michael's improv teacher. Lady, you went into the studio with him. I'm in Chicago, so I wasn't there, but it's such a great interview. Oh, he's just so wonderful. And I was just so glad we were able to snag him because he's about to leave to go out of town to do a project. And Michael and I have known each other a really long time. So this was like a fun reunion for two old friends. And Jenna, he said to say hello. You guys have the same manager, Naomi Odenkirk. We do. So we were talking about that. But it's a great interview. And then after the interview with Michael Norton, Cassie and I do a little limp prov. All right. Well, let's take a break.
他们不想让他追上。这简直，我当时想，哦，迈克尔。好吧，我很喜欢重温所有关于迈克尔即兴表演的额外镜头。那真的非常有趣。接下来，我们要听听迈克尔·诺顿的分享，他是饰演迈克尔即兴表演老师的演员。女士，你和他一起进了录音室。我在芝加哥，所以我不在那儿，但这是一场多么棒的采访。哦，他真的是太棒了。我很高兴我们能把他请来，因为他马上要离开外地去进行一个项目了。我和迈克尔认识很久了。所以这就像是两个老朋友的欢乐重逢。而且珍娜，他说向你问好。你们俩有同一个经纪人，娜奥米·奥登柯克。我们确实是。所以我们聊了那个。但这是一场很棒的采访。然后在大卫·诺顿的采访之后，我和卡西做了一小段即兴表演。好吧，我们休息一下。
break. And when we come back, Angela and Michael will talk about his time on the office and all of those hilarious improv scenes. With Amex Platinum, access to exclusive Amex pre-sale tickets can score you a spot trackside. So being a fan for life turns into the trip of a lifetime. That's the powerful backing of Amex. Pre-sale tickets for future events subject to availability and varied by race. Turns and conditions apply. Learn more at Amm. Simeons celebrates freedom of expression with a daily ritual of getting dressed. Fashion's power lies in its endless possibilities. Each garment is an invitation to get creative, be unique, and show the world exactly who you are as you are. Be true, be authentic, be unapologetically you. Express yourself at Simons.
休息一下。当我们回来时，安吉拉和迈克尔将谈论他在《办公室》的时光以及那些搞笑的即兴表演场景。使用美国运通白金卡，尊享独家美国运通预售门票，助您亲临赛道核心。让终身铁粉之旅，蜕变成为一生难忘的终极旅程。这就是美国运通的强大后盾。未来活动的预售门票视供应情况而定，且因赛事而异。条款与细则适用。了解更多请访问 Amm. Simons 通过日常的穿衣仪式来庆祝表达自由。时尚的力量在于其无限的可能性。每一件服装都是发出创意的邀请，展现独特自我，并如实向世界展现真实的你。保持真实，做你自己，毫不妥协地做自己。在 Simons 表达自我。
Hey, Michael. Hey. Oh, my God. Thanks for having me. Welcome to office ladies. Thank you. I'm so tickled to see you. It's office lady today.
嗨，迈克尔。嘿。哦，天哪。谢谢你能来。欢迎来到“办公室女士”。谢谢。看到你我太高兴了。今天是“办公室女士”。
It's today's office lady. But Jenna wishes she could be here. She says hi. She says hi. She says hi. She's in Chicago. She's doing her play, Ashland Avenue. Yeah, yeah.
今天是“办公室女士”。但珍娜希望她能来。她向你问好。她向你问好。她向你问好。她在芝加哥。她在演她的戏剧《阿什兰大道》。对，对。
Okay. Let's jump right in. We have a lot to discuss because you play Michael Scott's improv teacher and your character is so over his shenanigans. It's hilarious. Your character's name is Chris. Did you know that? No.
好吧。我们直接切入正题吧。我们有很多事情要讨论，因为你饰演迈克尔·斯科特的即兴表演老师，而且你的角色对他的胡闹简直忍无可忍。太搞笑了。你的角色叫克里斯。你知道吗？不。
It is? Yes, I went back to some old shooting draft scripts and table drafts. Your character's name was Chris. Do you know what's funny? Whenever someone gets my name wrong, you know, someone gets your name wrong, for some reason it's either Chris or David. Maybe. Do you look like a Chris?
是吗？是的，我翻阅了一些旧的拍摄剧本和桌面剧本。你的角色名字叫克里斯。你知道什么很有意思吗？每当有人把我的名字叫错时，你知道的，有人把你的名字叫错时，出于某种原因要么叫克里斯，要么叫大卫。也许吧。你长得像克里斯吗？
I guess so. And then Chris is so random. That was my character name. Yeah, that was your character name. I get Andrea sometimes. times from people like, hi, Andrea. And I'm like, I'm, I'm Angela. Hi, Andrea.
我想是的。然后克里斯太随机了。那是我的角色名字。对，那是你的角色名字。人们有时会叫我安德里亚。人们会说，嗨，安德里亚。我就说，我是，我是安吉拉。嗨，安德里亚。
But that kind of makes sense because it's close to your name. Kind of close. Like if you're not really listening. Yeah. Yeah. Which is funny to me because on the office, Creed's character called me Andrea the office bitch. I thought it was kind of perfect that he got my name wrong.
但这有点说得通，因为它跟你的名字很近。有点近。就像如果你没有真的在听一样。对。对。这对我来说很有趣，因为在《办公室》里，克里德的角色叫我安德里亚，那个办公室碧池。我觉得他把我的名字叫错了，简直完美极了。
Right. After your years. I'm going to just kick us off with some questions. Oh, wait. Actually, let's tell everyone how we know each other. Because we go way back. Yeah, yeah. Like, what's that expression?
对。在你呆了多年之后。我先抛出几个问题来开个头。哦，等等。其实，我们要告诉大家我们是怎么认识的。因为我们认识很久了。对，对。就像，那个词怎么说来着？
you're a sight for sore eyes. I'm so happy to be seeing you. So years ago, in our 20s? Yes. Yeah, yeah, 20s. So we met years ago, sort of in the improv circles, and then we ended up doing a sketch comedy show that you co-wrote called Balls Out.
久旱逢甘霖。很高兴见到你。所以多年前，在我们 20 多岁的时候？是的。对，对，20多岁。所以我们多年前认识的，大概是在即兴表演圈子里，然后我们最后一起做了一个你联合编剧的小品喜剧秀叫《Balls Out》。
Balls Out, yeah. Yeah, I remember where we first met. But yeah, yeah, balls out. Yeah, and I will never forget, I have to geek out on you a little bit. It's still one of the best, live performances I've ever seen. I am not, no, I'm not kidding.
《Balls Out》，对。对，我记得我们第一次见面。但是，对，对，《Balls Out》。对，我永远不会忘记，我得对你顶礼膜拜一下。这仍然是我看过的最棒的现场演出之一。我不是，不，我不是在开玩笑。
You did a monologue where you give a speech. And as you give the speech, we sort of learn stuff about your dad. Oh, yeah. Yeah, it was like a stand-up guy. Yeah. And he was like, I've been in therapy and just working through some things. And oh, my God, that was so long ago. And it was something like, I would like tell a joke and then you'd be like,
你做过一段独白，你在那里发表了一场演讲。随着你发表演讲，我们开始了解到关于你爸爸的一些事情。哦，对。对，就像一个挺不错的人。对。然后他说，我一直在接受治疗，只是在处理一些事情。然后，哦，天哪，那是很久以前的事了。大概是这样的，我会讲一个笑话，然后你就会说...
screw you, dad. Yeah, I think the setup was like, whenever I, um, talk about my life, my therapist kind of laughs. So I thought maybe I'll do some stand-up and make everybody laugh, you know, and then everything was revealing about how stand-up. Like the further he got into a stand-up set, the more deep he got into his therapy. And it was so funny. Thank you. I wish I could remember specific jokes, but yeah. No, it was so good. It was hilarious. Okay, I'm going to dive into some questions here for you. Here's a question we always ask all of our guests, which is how did you get your job on the office? Well, Alison Jones
去你的，老爸。是的，我想当时的设定是这样的，每当我，呃，谈到我的生活时，我的心理医生就会笑。所以我想也许我可以做点单口喜剧，让大家都笑一笑，你知道的，然后所有的事情都揭示了关于单口喜剧的内容。他的单口喜剧表演越深入，他在治疗中就陷得越深。这太搞笑了。谢谢。我希望我能记住具体的笑话，但是，是的。不，真的太棒了。太搞笑了。好吧，我要为你抛出一些问题了。这是我们总是问所有嘉宾的一个问题，那就是你是怎么得到《办公室》这份工作的？嗯，艾莉森·琼斯...
had brought me in for other things. I think I auditioned for another episode. I can't believe this was season two. I know. It was early. Yeah, I feel like when I auditioned, it was the office. We were already in our stride. Yeah, or at least like everybody in town loved the BBC version and now the American version. So everybody was trying to get on the office. I think I auditioned for something else. But I don't remember specifically the audition. Right. But it was through Allison. Yeah, yeah. I think it was my second audition. And yeah, I got the job. You know what? I remember being a little, not bummed, but like I knew you and I knew Oscar and Jenna a little bit. And we didn't get to work together. Yeah. And I was like, oh, I finally got the office. But I wanted to be in the office.
把我带去面试其他东西。我想我为另一集试镜过。真不敢相信这是第二季。我知道。很早。是的，我觉得当我试镜时，这就是《办公室》。我们已经渐入佳境了。是的，或者至少镇上的每个人都喜欢 BBC 版本，现在又喜欢美国版本。所以每个人都想加入《办公室》。我想我为别的东西试镜过。但我不记得具体的试镜了。对。但这是通过艾莉森安排的。对，对。我想那是我的第二次试镜。然后，是的，我得到了这份工作。你知道吗？我记得当时有点，倒不是沮丧，而是我认识你，我也稍微认识奥斯卡和珍娜。我们没能一起合作。是的。我就想，哦，我终于进了《办公室》。但我想要在办公室里工作。
I know. You were in the improv classroom. We didn't even see you on. set. I mean, it was still, I don't want to say, like, oh, I was bummed. Right, right. No, no, no, but I get it. I get it. It's like, that would have been a little bit of icing, right? Yeah, like, there's an office party or something, and I get to play with you guys, but. I know. You should have played, like, one of Angela Martin's love interests. It would have been really fun. It would have been fun for us. Okay. Wait, I'm sorry. Has everybody said this to you, like, I knew you from sketch comedy, and a lot of your characters are bubbly and sort of, has Everybody told you when you got cast in the office, like, she's the bitch?
我知道。你在即兴表演教室里。我们甚至没在片场看到你。我的意思是，这依然，我不想说，哦，我很沮丧。对，对。不，不，不，但我懂。我懂。这就好比，那本该是锦上添花，对吧？对，就像，有个办公室派对什么的，然后我有机会和你们一起玩，但我错过了。我知道。你本该扮演安吉拉·马丁的爱慕对象之一。那会非常有趣。对我们来说会很有趣的。好吧。等等，抱歉。每个人都对你说过这样的话吗，就像我从素描喜剧中认识你，你的很多角色都很活泼而且某种程度上，当你在《办公室》里试镜成功时，有人对你说过“她就是那个碧池”吗？
You know what? And you were so good, but it was just like so different than what I had seen you do. Well, thanks for saying that. Actually, you know who told me that? I did this show called Hators Back Off. And Steve Little plays my love interest in that. Really? And we had so much fun in our scenes.
你知道吗？而且你演得太棒了，但这跟我以前看你演的完全不同。好吧，谢谢你这么说。其实，你知道是谁跟我说过这个吗？我做过一个节目叫《网瘾患者退散》。史蒂夫·利特在里面演我的爱慕对象。真的吗？我们在那些场景里玩得很开心。
And we'd been working together for a few weeks. And then he, one day at lunch, he said, you know, Angela, I used to come to Improv Olympic and I would see you do improv. And you were always just sort of a bright, shiny, funny, like the shiny, bright, you know, kind of personality on stage. And he said, it was so wild for me to then see you as Angela Martin because it was so opposite of what I'd been doing. Yeah, yeah. I mean, again, you were great. It was just surprising the first few episodes. I'm like, wow.
我们一起工作了几个星期。然后他，有一天在午餐时，他说，你知道的，安吉拉，我以前经常去即兴奥运会，我看到你做即兴表演。你在舞台上总是那种明亮、闪耀、搞笑的，就像闪闪发光、开朗的，你知道的那种个性。他说，我当时看到你饰演安吉拉·马丁时觉得太疯狂了，因为这和我以前看到的你完全相反。对，对。我的意思是，再次声明，你演得很棒。只是前几集让人感到惊讶。我就想，哇。
I know. It was also really fun, though, because it was so different. than my regular come from, you know? Yeah, yeah. So that was really fun. Yeah. But very difficult for me not to laugh in scenes because I always had to be such a grump. Right, right.
我知道。不过这也真的很有趣，因为它和我平时出身的风格太不一样了，你知道的？对，对。所以那真的很有趣。对。但在场景中不笑对我来说太难了，因为我总是得扮演一个大老粗。对，对。
Like, I couldn't even have a little smile when Michael was up to some shenanigans. I had to be like, mm-hmm. Yeah, Jim could kind of, instead of breaking, he could do a little smirk or something. Yeah, he could smirk or Kelly could smirk. Or just Mindy would laugh, just on camera. She was a big breaker? Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah.
就像，当迈克尔在胡闹时，我甚至都不能露出一点微笑。我必须表现得像，嗯哼。对，吉姆可以，他不会笑场，而是可以做一个邪魅的一笑或者别的什么。对，他可以坏笑，或者凯莉可以坏笑。或者明迪会笑，直接在镜头前。她是个笑场大王吗？哦，是的。哦，是的。
She would just, like, she tried to hide. it in the beginning. And then I think at the end, she just was like, I'm just going to break. Okay, next question. What do you remember about that day of filming those improv scenes? Do you have any behind the scenes stories? Do you know what I do remember? Yes, Kim Jong. Yeah. I remember, I knew, because I think he was a big stand-up at the time. And I'm like, oh, he's a doctor and he seems so sweet because he was a real doctor.
她总是，她一开始试图掩饰。然后我觉得最后她只是觉得，我干脆直接笑场好了。好吧，下一个问题。关于拍摄那些即兴表演场景的那天，你还记得什么？你有什么幕后故事吗？你知道我还记得什么吗？是的，金康。是的。我记得，我知道，因为我觉得他当时是个很棒的单口喜剧演员。我想，哦，他是个医生，他看起来人真好，因为他是个真正的医生。
And then, oh, he's also trying to do acting. And I just thought He was such a sweet guy And he took a picture With Steve Carell And I'm thinking like I'm an actor I'm a peer
然后，哦，他也在尝试演戏。我当时就觉得他真是个好人，而且他和史蒂夫·卡瑞尔合了影。我当时在想，我是一个演员，我是个同行。
I'm not going to take a picture Like a fan You're like how cute The doctor wants a picture Yeah how cute And then Maybe a year later He started
我才不拍照呢，像个粉丝一样。你就像是，真可爱，医生想拍张照。对，真可爱。然后也许一年后，他开始...
I started seeing him and stuff And then the Vegas I'm blanking The hangover The hangover Yeah And I had no idea Like he was this
我开始到处看到他之类的。然后是《宿醉》，我记不起来了，《宿醉》。是的。我完全不知道他竟然是这种...
Twisted That he had such Crazy sense of humor Yeah Yeah. Like, I had no idea. So that was pretty funny. I just thought, oh, this sweet doctor. Sweet doctor. Got a couple lines on the office. But I do remember just feeling really comfortable, just kind of loose, like improvising. Because I rewatched the episode recently. And, yeah, everybody is very friendly. And I, you know, because coming in for a day thing on the office. And you had some real improvisers in that room. You had Dee Ryan, who I had done improv with at iOS. You had Wyatt Snack. I was on a Harold team with Wyatt. were you? Yeah. So you definitely had some folks in there that new improv. And Colleen Smith?
扭曲的是，他竟然有那种疯狂的幽默感，对吧，对吧。就像，我完全不知道。所以那真的挺好笑的。我当时心想，哦，这个温柔的医生。温柔的医生。在办公室里有几句台词。不过我确实记得感觉非常舒服，整个人很放松，就像即兴发挥一样。因为我最近重温了那一集。而且，是的，每个人都非常友好。而且我，你知道的，因为我是去《办公室》客串一天。而且那个房间里有一些真正的即兴演员。你有迪·赖恩，我和他在iOS一起做过即兴。你有怀亚特·斯纳克。我和怀亚特在一个黑罗（Harold）小分队里。是吗？对。所以你房间里绝对有一些懂即兴表演的人。还有科琳·史密斯？
Yes. You know her? Okay. Yeah. She's a friend of mine. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Some good improvisers. But I mean, in terms of the show giving me the confidence to sort of improv within the lines and stuff and feel comfortable. Well, I watched the super fan version, you know, and then I also watch all of those deleted scenes. There are so many that even with the super fan version, David Rogers, who, you know, has sort of been putting these. episodes back together. He didn't even get to use all of them because I feel like they just hit, hit, like, record on the camera and let you guys play a little bit. And I have to share one, okay? I'm going to set it up. Okay. So basically, in the improv class, two people are starting a scene. And Chris, the improv teacher, is like, okay, I need everyone to pair up and get a scene
是的。你认识她？好吧。对。她是个朋友。对。对。对。有些不错的即兴演员。但我的意思是，就节目给我的自信而言，让我能够在台词范围内即兴发挥什么的，并且感到舒服。好吧，我看了超级粉丝版，你知道的，然后我还看了所有那些被删减的片段。有太多了，以至于即使有了超级粉丝版，大卫·罗杰斯（你知道的，他一直在把这些剧集重新拼凑起来）甚至没能用上所有这些，因为我觉得他们只是按下了摄像机的录制键，然后让你们随便玩了一会。我必须分享一个，好吗？我来铺垫一下。好吧。所以基本上，在即兴表演课上，两个人正在开始一个场景。然后克里斯，即兴表演老师，就说，好了，我需要每个人两两组队，找一个场景
partner. And no one wants to pair up with Michael. Because his bit is to just, you know, kill everyone he's in a scene with. So no one wants to be his partner anymore. Right, right. By the way, did you know, Steve based that on someone that he did improv with? Did he really? Yes, in every scene. Specifically, the guns? Yes, he talks about it that he would like take out everyone in the scene. No. Yeah. So anyway, Chris, the improv teacher, has asked everyone to partner up. Michael has left out. And so Chris, the improv teacher is like, just sit over here. Okay, why don't you just sit? Why don't you go outside, but Michael doesn't go outside. He stays in the room. He can't not, shut up. He keeps yelling suggestions. I did re-watch this the other day in preparation for
搭档。然后没有人想和迈克尔组队。因为他的套路就是，你知道的，毁掉和他同台的每一个人。所以再也没有人想当他的搭档了。对，对。顺便问一下，你知道吗，史蒂夫这个角色是根据他一起做过即兴表演的一个人创作的？真的吗？是的，在每个场景中。具体来说，是枪吗？是的，他谈到过那个人会在场景中干掉所有人。不会吧。对。所以不管怎样，克里斯，即兴表演老师，让每个人都找搭档。迈克尔被落下了。然后克里斯，即兴表演老师就说，就坐在这儿。好吧，你为什么不坐？你为什么不去外面，但迈克尔没有去外面。他留在了房间里。他忍不住，闭不上嘴。他一直在大喊建议。我前几天为了准备
this. But yeah, he keeps... Wait, let's hear it. Can we play that? Okay. For the next exercise, let's everyone pair up. A partner and... Everybody got somebody? Uh-huh. Okay, good. Okay. Why don't you go in the hallway and just go through all those rules in your head? observe over here. Okay, but don't, okay, you take break and just sort of run through the rules in your head. Okay, stay there.
这个又重新看了这一段。但是，等等，我们听听看。我们能放一下那个吗？好的。对于下一个练习，大家两两组队。一个搭档和……大家都找到人了吗？嗯哼。好吧，很好。好吧，你们为什么不去走廊里，在脑子里过一遍那些规则？在这边观察。好吧，但是别，好吧，你休息一下，就在脑子里过一遍规则。好吧，呆在那儿。
I'll just throw in some suggestions. Okay, you guys want to start? Don't throw any suggestions, okay, we don't need a suggestion for this one. Okay, this one's gonna come from them. This one's gonna come from them. It's game called yes and, and you will say the first sentence. First sentence is, I am a proctologist.
我只提几个建议。好吧，你们想开始吗？不要提任何建议，好吧，我们不需要这个建议。好吧，这个要听他们的。这个要听他们的。这是一个叫“是的，而且”的游戏，而你会说第一句话。第一句话是，我是一名直肠科医生。
We're not gonna get a suggestion on this one that's gonna come from them, okay. You're going to say the first sentence, and then she will say yes to that, and then she'll add something to the story, like you're telling a story. What were you? What was he doing? Okay. Why don't you take a break, since you don't have a partner? All right here.
我们这个不用听建议，这个要听他们的，好吧。你要说第一句话，然后她会对那个说“好的”，然后她会在故事中添加一些内容，就像你在讲故事一样。你刚才是什么？他在干什么？好吧。既然你没有搭档，你为什么不休息一下？就在这儿。
Okay. Was that scripted? I went and checked the script. It wasn't scripted, so I really felt like there were some loose elements to this sort of these improv scenes. But yeah, he keeps trying to make suggestions and they're horrible. And you're just, you're looking at him. Yeah. Proctologist is just the most basic. Yeah. What? And then you're in a hor house or you're proctologist. Then you're like no more suggestions. And you're, your back is to him. He's behind you. And you face the two people who are starting the scene. And
好吧。那是按剧本演的吗？我去查了剧本。那不是按剧本演的，所以我真的觉得这些即兴场景有一些松散的元素。但是，是的，他一直在试图提出建议，而且都很糟糕。而你只是，你在看着他。是的。直肠科医生是最基本的。什么？然后你在红灯区或者你是直肠科医生。然后你就好像说，不要再提建议了。然后你，你背对着他。他在你身后。你面对着正在开始场景的那两个人，然后
then he's like whispering behind you. And you're like, stop it. But I could not have gotten through those. And you can see people. kind of trying not to break. Uh-huh. I was just like, I had to ask you, what was it like to be in those scenes with Steve? Because he himself is such a great improviser, and that was all off script.
接着他在你身后低声说个不停。而你就好像说，住手。但是我简直无法熬过那些镜头。你可以看到人们尽量忍住不笑场。嗯哼。我当时就想，我不得不问你，和史蒂夫一起拍那些场景是什么感觉？因为他自己就是一个非常棒的即兴演员，而且那完全是脱离剧本的。
You know, I feel like in the growlings, I could be a breaker, you know? And some people hate that. Like, you know, you see people break and, like, just stay in the scenes, stay in character. Then I was guilty of that, but I feel like if I'm on a show and I'm just there for a day,
你知道的，我觉得在那些拍摄中，我可能会笑场，你知道吗？有些人讨厌这样。就像，你知道的，你看到有人笑场，然后，就留在场景里，保持角色。那我确实犯过这种错，但我觉得如果我在一个节目里，我只是去呆一天，
I don't know if you're nervous or just like, I just want to do everything. everything right. So I don't remember feeling tempted to break no matter how funny it was. I was just like, I'm going to do my job. I'm a mistake. But that was, I don't know, my mindset. That's amazing. I was like, I'm not going to break. My memory was that like finally maybe Steve would break or maybe someone off like a producer or someone would break. Then you could laugh. Then gave the room permission to laugh. Yeah. But I'm like, I'm not going to ruin this take because I don't know what they're going to use and they're just like I didn't know like the scripted dialogue ends and then
我不知道你是不是很紧张，或者只是想把所有事情都做好。只想把一切都做对。所以无论它有多搞笑，我都不觉得有想笑场的冲动。我当时只想，我要做好我的工作。我是一个失误。但那是，我不知道，我的心态。这太惊人了。我当时想，我绝对不笑场。我的记忆是，最后可能史蒂夫会笑场，或者制片人之类的人会笑场。然后你就可以笑了。然后这给了全场大笑的许可。是的。但我想，我不会毁掉这个镜头的，因为我不知道他们会用哪个，而且他们就像，我不知道，剧本对话结束了，然后
I'm kind of going oh we're still going yeah I guess they didn't call okay they didn't call cut so that's exactly what happened in this scene I think okay you can see where the script would have ended and they just let you guys keep going and um but I was not going to be the one to you did not break you know so there was one scene though where I I felt like I saw people starting to break just a little and it is when you it's so funny Michael keeps killing everyone in all his scenes. And so you turn to him and you say, give me all the guns.
我有点不知所措，哦，我们还在继续吗？好吧，我想他们没有喊停，好吧，他们没有喊停，所以这正是这个场景中发生的事情，我想，好吧，你能看出剧本本来应该在哪里结束，而他们只是让你们继续演下去，嗯，但我才不要做那个笑场的人，你没有笑场，你知道，不过有一个场景，我觉得我看到大家开始有点要笑场了，就是当你，太搞笑了，迈克尔在所有的场景里都在干掉所有人。于是你转向他，你说，把所有的枪都交出来。
And they're all. And they're just. They're air. You know, he's just handing you his improv. Right, but he knows where they are. Yeah.
而他们全都是。而且他们只是。它们是空气。你知道的，他只是把他的即兴道具交给你。没错，但他知道它们在哪里。是的。
And he takes him out of all his pockets. Yeah, yeah. And then you're like, fine. And now the next scene is Michael and Ken's character. And he's like, freeze. And like, Ken Jong has his hands up. And then Michael whispers something in his ear. And you're like,
然后他把它们从他所有的口袋里掏出来。对，对。然后你说，好吧。现在下一个场景是迈克尔和肯的角色。然后他说，不许动。就像，肯·郑举起了双手。然后迈克尔在他耳边低声说了些什么。然后你就好像说，
I remember this. Yeah. You're like, what did he say? And Ken's like, he told me not to say, but he has a gun, you know. That was scripted, right? Yeah, that was scripted. But I could see people just in the background, just like, and how ridiculous it was. I can't believe that was a real thing that someone in a class did that.
我记得这个。是的。你就好像说，他说什么了？然后肯说，他叫我别说，但他有枪，你知道的。那是按剧本演的吧？是的，那是按剧本演的。但我能看到背景里的人，只是那种，这太荒谬了。我不敢相信那是真有人在班上做过的事。
Because everybody has seen that person in improv class that doesn't play long. They just came home with your whole thing. But I thought that was an absurd version of it that the guy brings a gun in every time. And that was a real person. He just wanted to be the only person left on stage, just so he could do his own bits. Right, right. But I shared this before. There was a guy, I was on a Harold team one time, and it didn't matter what you said is the first line.
因为每个人都在即兴表演课上见过那种不肯好好配合的人。他只是来砸你的场子。但我认为这是一个荒谬的版本，那家伙每次都带一把枪。而且那是一个真人。他只是想成为舞台上唯一剩下的人，好让他自己演独角戏。没错，没错。但我之前分享过这个。有一个家伙，我曾经在一个黑罗小分队里，不管你把第一句话说什么，
He never yes-anded it. So you could be like, welcome to, you know, Chris's coffee shop. I've got a selection of muffins here. And he would say, how dare you do that to my cat? You know, like, wait, we're at a muffin shop. Like, you didn't even hear it. Yeah, yeah. And I'm like, I'm sorry about your cat. And then he would be like, I'm a detective. You're like, what? It just would get weirder and weirder. And then he would be like, you're no longer my cousin. What? It's just like, anyway. But what we all collectively. Did he get better? Did he improve his improv? He didn't. He always came in with his own script. My favorite thing is when a scene would have been going for a while. So let's say we're two nurses on our break, right? And we're having. having lunch.
他从来不说“是的，而且”。所以你可以说，欢迎来到，你知道的，克里斯的咖啡店。这里有我精选的松饼。而他会说，你怎么能对我的猫做出这种事？你知道的，就像，等等，我们在一家松饼店。就像，你根本没听见。对，对。而我说，我很遗憾听到你的猫的事。然后他会说，我是一名侦探。你就好像说，什么？事情会变得越来越诡异。然后他会说，你不再是我的表弟了。什么？这简直是，不管怎样。但我们大家共同的。他有变好吗？他的即兴表演有进步吗？没有。他总是带着他自己写好的剧本。我最喜欢的事情是，当一个场景已经演了一会儿。比如说我们是两个正在休息的护士，对吧？我们在吃午饭。
And this scene is about two nurses in a hospital. It's been going for a few minutes. Right, right. And he would come in and be like, hey, where's your clown mask? You're late for the clown show. And we're like, we, what? And then you have to integrate it. Like, yes, we're.
这个场景是关于医院里的两个护士。已经演了几分钟了。没错，没错。然后他会走进来，说，嘿，你的小丑面具呢？你的小丑表演要迟到了。我们就会说，我们，什么？然后你必须把这个圆回来。就像，是的，我们。
We also are clowns. Nursing gets so hard. We need something fun. After our shift, we do a full clown show. There was no teacher to go. No teacher to say. But we would get notes afterwards for my. coach, and they'd be like, once again, they were nurses, and you decided to make them clown.
我们其实也是小丑。护理工作太难了。我们需要点有趣的东西。下班后，我们有一场完整的小丑表演。当时没有老师出来说。没有老师出来说。但我们事后会从我的教练那里得到评语，他们会说，又来了，她们是护士，而你决定让她们变成小丑。
Yeah, I thought it was funny. Yeah, that scene wasn't going anywhere. Anyway, so. I really kicked it up a notch. Anyway, but sometimes you do have people like that in improv, and that was Michael Scott. He was the steamroller. Yeah, you totally have people like that. But I thought you brought some of your own life experience to Chris, the improv teacher,
对，我觉得挺搞笑的。对，那个场景本来也没什么进展。不管怎样，总之。我真的把它提升了一个档次。无论如何，但有时即兴表演中确实会有这样的人，而那个人就是迈克尔·斯科特。他就是那个推土机。对，你完全会遇到这样的人。但我觉得你把一些自己的人生经验带到了克里斯（这个即兴表演老师）身上，
because your background is improv and sketch comedy and. Were there, it must have been sort of a very organic fit for you. Yeah, I didn't teach that much, but being in class, there's always that guy. Yeah. It's funny, though, I don't know how many improv classes Michael Scott had, but I feel like by the time you meet me, I'm not very nurturing. Like, he's done this a bunch. I feel like I'm over him. Oh, you're so fed up with him.
因为你的背景是即兴表演和素描喜剧，还有。有没有，对你来说这一定是一个非常自然的契合点。是的，我教得不多，但上课时，总会有那种家伙。是的。不过很有趣的是，我不知道迈克尔·斯科特上过多少次即兴表演课，但我觉得当你遇到我的时候，我并不是很懂得循循善诱。你看，他已经做过很多次了。我觉得我已经受够他了。哦，你对她太厌烦了。
Like the first time you see him, I'm just. That look, you give to camera when he's doing all of his shenanigans. I got the camera look. I got the office. Yeah, you got the classic gym to camera. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, I mean, it's definitely experience, but yeah, I thought that was funny that you don't see me grow annoyed with him.
就像你第一次见到他时，我只是。那个眼神，当他搞砸一切时，你给镜头的那个眼神。我得到了那个镜头。我得到了《办公室》的精髓。对，你得到了经典的吉姆式看向镜头。对。对。对，我的意思是，这绝对是经验之谈，但是，是的，我觉得很有趣的是，你不会看到我对他的烦恼有所增长。
It seems like it's a few classes in. Oh, God, he came tonight. Okay, so a question we always ask our folks that come on as well is, do you still get recognized from your role in the office? I do, but it's been going on for so long, like during the pandemic. I think people watched it a lot more. Oh, yeah, people binged it during the pandemic. Yeah, yeah. And so now, like, we've watched it so many times.
看起来像是已经上了好几节课了。哦，天哪，他今晚又来了。好吧，所以我们总是问那些来参加节目录制的嘉宾的一个问题是，你现在还会因为在《办公室》里的角色而被认出来吗？我会的，但这已经持续太久了，比如在疫情期间。我觉得人们看的次数要多得多。哦，是的，人们在疫情期间疯狂刷剧。对，对。所以现在，就像，我们已经看了很多很多遍了。
kind of on your third or fourth viewing. I feel like I get a lot of people I've known for a few years, like kids, you know, friends, parents, like, oh, my God, I was rewatching. I didn't realize that was you. Like, I get a lot of that. Like, people I've known. And then. They're connecting the dots later.
差不多看到第三遍或第四遍了。我觉得有很多我认识好几年的人，比如孩子们，你知道的，朋友的父母，就像，哦，天哪，我当时在重温。我没意识到那是你。就像，我经常遇到这种情况。就像我认识的人。然后。他们后来把这些线索串联起来了。
Yeah. Yeah. More than like a guy off the street. Like, you know. But yeah, yeah, I get it a lot. Yeah. I had that one of my daughter's friends who, you know, I've known this kid since kindergarten. Her and my daughter are like best buddies.
对。对。比街上随便一个人认出来要多。就像，你知道的。不过对，对，我经常遇到。是的。我女儿的一个朋友就这样，你知道的，我从这孩子上幼儿园起就认识她了。她和我女儿是铁磁。
And it was sometime around, like, sixth grade. She started watching the office, and she's been in my house countless times and sleepovers. And then one day she was like, wait a second. She was like, she didn't know how to act around me one day. I'm like, it's still me. She made the connection. Curious LaMorton. Yeah.
那大概是在六年级的时候。她开始看《办公室》，而且她来过我家无数次，还留宿过。然后有一天她突然说，等一下。她就好像，有一天她不知道该怎么面对我了。我说，我还是我。她把这些联系起来了。好奇的拉莫顿。所以看她意识到这一点挺有意思的。
So it was kind of fun to see her realize that. Yeah, yeah. But are you watching it with your kids you were saying? Yeah. I mean, definitely. They're 11 and 14th. So we're through it. You know, at first, Luca, it's Luca 11, Parker, 14, shout out.
对，对。但你刚才说你在和你的孩子们一起看？对。当然。他们11岁和14岁。所以我们已经看完了。你知道的，一开始，卢卡，卢卡11岁，帕克14岁，大声喊出来。
Shout out to my kids. My wife, Laura. What's up, family? What's up, Nottons? They'll listen. Sorry, everybody else. I have to hear me list, my family. We've been launching it for a few years.
向我的孩子们大声致敬。我的妻子，劳拉。怎么了，家人们？怎么了，诺顿一家？他们会听的。抱歉，其他人。我得念我的家人。我们已经追这部剧好几年了。
At first, Luca, it was a little tough. The worst parts for her, you know, because when you're young, it's just like, oh, these people are married, these people are together. Was a lot of your storyline when you were with Dwight. Yeah, she was confused. She just didn't like, like, oh, wait, but she's with. But, and poor Andy. Yeah, yeah, poor Andy. So we had to skip over because, you know, there's a lot of like, I don't know, sexual references and stuff.
一开始，对卢卡来说，有点艰难。对她来说最糟糕的部分，你知道的，因为当你还年轻的时候，就会觉得，哦，这些人结婚了，这些人在一起了。其中很大一部分是当你和德怀特在一起时的剧情。是的，她很困惑。她只是不喜欢，就像，哦，等等，但她和。但是，还有可怜的安迪。对，对，可怜的安迪。所以我们不得不跳过去，因为，你知道的，有很多，我不知道，色情暗示之类的内容。
But it was mostly that that made her a little sad. I mean, now we're full on, you know, we can watch everything. Yeah. But at first she was confused. Like, no, people are a couple and they don't. And Angela is the first to call Pam the office mattress, but Angela made her round. Yeah. I know.
但主要还是那些内容让她有点难过。我的意思是，现在我们可以全力以赴地，你知道的，我们可以看所有内容了。是的。但一开始她很困惑。就像，不，人们是一对情侣，但他们却没有。而安吉拉是第一个叫潘“办公室床垫”的人，但安吉拉也经历过风雨。对。我知道。
But yeah. Do they have a favorite episode, your kids? Oh, boy. Favorite episode? Or as a family? Do you have one that's like your family favorite? I don't know. There's so many years of.
不过，是的。他们有最喜欢的剧集吗，你的孩子们？哦，天哪。最喜欢的剧集？或者作为一家人？你们有没有哪一集是全家人最喜欢的？不知道。有那么多年。
Email surveillance. Yeah, email surveillance. Dad's episode for sure. Yeah. I mean, now that we're talking about it, probably the marriage episode, is that a two-parter? Oh, yes. Niagara Falls. Niagara Falls.
《电子邮件监视》。对，《电子邮件监视》。爸爸的那一集，绝对的。是的。我的意思是，既然我们在谈论这个，可能是结婚那一集，那是上下两集吗？哦，是的。尼亚加拉大瀑布。尼亚加拉大瀑布。
That's pretty fun. Yeah. And everybody dancing down the aisles. That's pretty... That was really fun. Fun. But do you have a favorite moment? Like, your character got to do something unusually.
那挺有趣的。是的。每个人都在过道里跳舞。那挺……那真的很有趣。有趣。但你有没有最喜欢的时刻？比如，你的角色做了一些不寻常的事情。
Some of my absolute favorite scenes when I look back on them are between Angela and Oscar. Like when Angela and Oscar kind of discover together that the senator has another person, not either of them. Right, right. And then when they also leave him a voicemail that they possibly outed him in the this documentary, just all those little nuanced moments of, you know, they, Oscar drove Angela crazy and she would judge him, but then she also, when everything, you know, went south for her, he's who was there for her and took her in. And so there, I don't know, I always thought their relationship was really fun. Yeah, they finally were on the same team. And of course, I love Dwight and Angela,
当我回想起来时，我绝对最喜欢的一些场景是安吉拉和奥斯卡之间的。比如安吉拉和奥斯卡一起发现参议员还有另一个人，都不是他们俩。对，对。然后还有当他们给他留语音留言，说他们可能在这个纪录片里曝光了他的时候，所有那些微妙的时刻，你知道的，奥斯卡把安吉拉快逼疯了，她总是对评头论足，但后来当一切，你知道的，对她来说急转直下时，正是他在那里支持她并收留了她。所以，我不知道，我一直觉得他们的关系真的很有趣。是的，他们终于站在同一战线了。当然，我喜欢德怀特和安吉拉，
and I love all of that and the cat stuff. And, and I think one of my favorite speeches I ever gave on the entire show was to Phyllis when I'm like, Phyllis, these are forks. Forks have prongs. Because you get to be so mean. Yeah, that speech was really fun. Well, Michael, can we share anything that you're working on right now or anything I might have missed and give a shout out to?
我喜欢所有那些还有猫的梗。而且，我认为我在整部剧中发表过的最喜欢的演讲之一就是对菲利斯说的，当时我说，菲利斯，这是叉子。叉子有叉尖。因为你可以表现得很刻薄。是的，那段演讲真的很有趣。好吧，迈克尔，我们可以分享一下你现在正在进行的工作，或者我可能错过的事情，并向他们致意吗？
Yeah, I just did a film in Kentucky, like a low-budget film. A friend of mine, Lisa Shurga. from the groundlings. I don't know if you know her. Good friend and a friend Mike Day. They wrote it together. And it's a comedic version of 12 Angry Men. Okay.
可以，我刚在肯塔基州拍了一部电影，一部低成本电影。我的一个朋友，丽莎·舒加，来自地雷剧团。我不知道你是否认识她。好朋友，还有一个朋友迈克·戴。他们一起写的剧本。这是《十二怒汉》的喜剧版。好吧。
If you remember that from the 60s or whatever. Which is a great idea for like a low budget film because you got one room. But it was really fun. It was just everybody in the cast was like groundlings or legendary alum of the groundlings. It was just so many really funny people in one room. And so I mean, we just shot it a few weeks. weeks go, so who knows. You'll have to let us know when it's out and I'll share it. Whenever it is, just, you know,
如果你还记得60年代或什么的那个版本的话。这对于低成本电影来说真是一个绝妙的主意，因为你只需要一个房间。但真的很有趣。演员阵容里的每个人都来自地雷剧团或者是地雷剧团的传奇校友。一个房间里有那么多真正搞笑的人。所以，我的意思是，我们几周前才刚拍完。谁知道呢。等它上映的时候你得告诉我们一声，我会分享的。无论什么时候，只要，你知道的，
text me because I'll share with everyone so we can all go find it. Okay. Yeah, yeah. I think it'll be, yeah, pretty good. Well, Michael, this has been so delightful. Oh, good. Thanks for having me. Yeah, I'm so happy to see you. All right, Michael, thank you so much. Thank you. Thank you. Michael Notting in the house, everybody. Oh, Angela Kinsey.
发短信告诉我就行，我会分享给每个人，这样我们都可以去找来看看。好吧。对，对。我想这会，是的，挺不错的。好吧，迈克尔，这真是太愉快了。太好了。谢谢你邀请我。是的，很高兴见到你。好的，迈克尔，非常感谢你。谢谢。谢谢。迈克尔·诺廷驾到，各位。哦，安吉拉·金西。
Woohoo. This episode is brought to you by Peloton. A new era of fitness is here. Introducing the new Peloton Cross Training Tread Plus, powered by Peloton IQ. Built for breakthroughs with personalized workout plans, real-time insights, and endless ways to move. Lift with confidence, while Peloton IQ counts reps, corrects form, and tracks your progress. Let yourself run, lift, flow, and go. Explore the new Peloton Cross Training Tread Plus at OnePeloton.ca.
呜呼。本期节目由 Peloton 赞助播出。健身新时代已经到来。隆重推出全新的 Peloton Cross Training Tread Plus，搭载 Peloton IQ 技术。专为突破而生，配备个性化健身计划、实时洞察和无限运动方式。自信举重，而 Peloton IQ 会计算重复次数、纠正姿势并追踪你的进度。尽情奔跑、举重、流动并前行。请前往 OnePeloton.ca 探索全新的 Peloton Cross Training Tread Plus。
Calling all book lovers. The Toronto International Festival of Authors brings you a world of stories all in one place. Discover five days of readings, talks, workshops and more, with over 100 authors from around the world, including Rachel Maddow, Ketourou Isaku and Kieran Desai. The Toronto International Festival of Authors, October 29th to November 2nd. Details and tickets at Festival of Authors.ca. Okay, guys, we are back, and it's time to start our improv. We have two fantastic improvisers here today, Marcus and Connor.
所有爱书之人请注意。多伦多国际作家节为您将世界各地的故事汇聚一地。探索为期五天的朗诵、讲座、工作坊等活动，汇聚来自世界各地的100多位作家，包括雷切尔·马多、藤富伊萨库和基兰·德赛。多伦多国际作家节，10月29日至11月2日。详情与门票请访问 Festival of Authors.ca。好了，各位，我们回来了，是时候开始我们的即兴表演了。今天我们请到了两位非常棒的即兴演员，马库斯和康纳。
You guys, will you tell us a little bit about yourselves? Oh, man, it's great to be here. First of all, I'm Marcus Fulmar. I grew up. How far back do we want to go? I grew up most of my life in Denver, Colorado. Oh, we're going that far back. Yeah, we're going there.
你们两个，能跟我们简单介绍一下你们自己吗？天哪，很高兴能来到这里。首先，我是马库斯·富尔玛。我是在……我们要追溯到多远以前？我大部分时间都在科罗拉多州丹佛市长大。哦，我们要追溯到那么久以前吗？是的，我们要追溯到那儿。
But we'll jump there in Northwestern University. See how we're doing that? And that brings us to LA where I have improvised at UCB. I was on Harold Night Bear for a long time and I write as well. I have a play. I'm currently
但我们会跳到西北大学。看我们是怎么做到的？这就把我们带到了洛杉矶，我一直在UCB进行即兴表演。我在“黑罗之夜”呆了很久，我也写作。我目前正在
pushing called Chicken Stories. Yeah. You know, a lot of fun stuff. A lot of fun stuff. Go Broncos. Okay. And well, I may, I'm Connor and I may as well start back when my parents met. So this would have been this is a little awkward, Connor.
推介一部名为《鸡的故事》的戏剧。对，很多有趣的东西。很多有趣的东西。野马队加油。好的。那么，也许，我是康纳，我不妨从我父母相遇的时候开始讲起。所以这会是，这有点尴尬，康纳。
Yeah, I want to push the origin story a little farther back. I'm Connor McCabe, also a writer, actor, improviser, was also on Harold Night at UCB Theater with Marcus for years. And I mean, that's how Cassie and I met each other was doing indie improv back in the day. But, yeah, I host a video game podcast called Call Me By Your Game and just got my fingers in a lot of pies. That's how I sort of pitch myself. And are any of them warm? I don't think so.
是的，我想把起源故事再往前推一点。我是康纳·麦凯布，也是一名作家、演员、即兴演员，也和马库斯一起在UCB剧院的“黑罗之夜”呆了好几年。我的意思是，我和卡茜就是当年在独立即兴表演中认识的。但是，是的，我主持一个名为《以你的游戏呼唤我》的电子游戏播客，而且我涉足很多领域。这就是我向别人推销自己的方式。它们当中有哪个是温热的吗？我想没有吧。
But my fingers are in. I like it. I think that's your go-to, finger in the pie guy. I'm not sure. Yeah, actually, as I say it out loud, might doll that back. All right.
但我的手确实伸进去了。我喜欢。我觉得这是你的招牌动作，涉猎广泛的家伙。我不确定。是的，其实当我大声说出来时，可能会收敛一点。好吧。
So we need a suggestion of a location and maybe a relationship. What do you guys think? Yeah. Yes, and we're going to take those suggestions. We're going to use them as a jumping off point to do some long-form improv. We'll do a series of scenes inspired by those suggestions.
所以我们需要一个地点和可能的关系的建议。你们觉得呢？是的。没错，我们会采用这些建议。我们将以它们为起点来进行长篇即兴表演。我们将做一系列受这些建议启发而创作的场景。
All right, let's call someone for suggestions. We can't make our own. own suggestions, you guys. That's true. We don't have an audience here. We need to call someone. Yes, we didn't write any of this before. No.
好了，我们打个电话征求建议吧。我们不能自己提出建议，各位。没错。我们这里没有观众。我们需要给别人打电话。是的，我们之前没有写任何剧本。没有。
So it has to start with the suggestion from someone else. That's right. Okay, Cassie, why don't you call a friend? Okay. Who are you going to call? I should have thought about this. Oh, no. Are you guys could call someone?
所以它必须从别人的建议开始。没错。好吧，卡茜，你为什么不给朋友打个电话？好吧。你要打给谁？我应该提前想好这个的。哦，不。你们俩能给谁打电话？
No, I have a text message from my friend Tim Newman. Okay. And he's going to, when he answers, he's going to be like, hello? Like, he's going to think something's very wrong. Put your phone up to the mic so we hear his confusion. It's true. Let's see me. Hey, what's up, Cassie?
不，我有一条来自我朋友蒂姆·纽曼的短信。好吧。当他接电话时，他会说，喂？就像，他会觉得有什么大问题。把你的手机贴近麦克风，这样我们能听到他的困惑。确实如此。看我。嘿，怎么了，卡茜？
Hey, Tim. How's it going? That's a pretty confident. Hello? He already doesn't like this. I know. What's going on? We are recording an episode of Office ladies.
嘿，蒂姆。最近怎么样？这是一个相当自信的。喂？他已经不喜欢这样了。我知道。怎么回事？我们正在录制一期《办公室女士》的播客。
Woo-woo. And we're going to do an improv set. We're wondering if you could give us a location. Oh, location for an improv set. A kid's birthday party. Okay. Oh, that's so good. We love that.
呜呼。我们要做一个即兴表演。我们想知道你能不能给我们提供一个地点。哦，即兴表演的地点。小孩子的生日派对。好的。哦，太棒了。我们喜欢这个。
Thank you, Tim. I'll talk to you later. Off Mike. Okay, bye. Okay, that's fantastic. My turn, I'm going to call, let's see. Kate Flannery and I did an improv show together for years called Bitch Planet. She's on the road right now.
谢谢你，蒂姆。我晚点跟你聊。离开麦克风。好的，拜拜。好的，太棒了。轮到我了，我要打给，让我想想。凯特·弗兰内里和我一起做过多年的即兴喜剧秀叫《贱人星球》。她现在正在巡演中。
I want to call her. Let's see if she answers. Classic pair, Kate. Yeah. She has no idea I'm calling her. She's on tour with Jane Lynch right now. Oh, fine. So she could be on a plane.
我想打给她。看看她接不接。经典搭档，凯特。对。她根本不知道我给她打电话。她现在正和简·林奇一起巡演。哦，好吧。所以她可能在飞机上。
And? Hey, Kate, you're on speakerphone on my podcast. Just really. Sorry to do that, but we're doing an improv set. We're going to do a little improv show, and I didn't want anything to seem stage. So that's why I'm calling you out of the blue. And as my gal, who was on Girl Team Ball. with me. Kate, we need a suggestion of a relationship. I'm going to say decorator and client.
然后呢？嘿，凯特，你正在我的播客的免提通话中。真的非常。抱歉这么做，但我们在做一个即兴表演。我们要做一个小型即兴喜剧秀，我不想让任何事情看起来像彩排。所以我才突然打电话给你。作为我的好姐妹，她曾和我在“女孩战队”里。
Oh, that's so good. Oh, gosh. Okay, thank you, Kate. I love you. I'll call you later. Bitch planet forever. Bitch planet. Woohoo. Bye. She said bitch planet forever. That is so good. She did not know our other. Yeah, she does not know Tim. Right. So she didn't know birthday party. Okay, so what do we have Guys, we have kids' birthday party and our relationship. Planner and Client? Yes. Yeah. Like, party planner and client.
凯特，我们需要一个关于关系的建议。我要说的是装饰师和客户。哦，太棒了。哦，天哪。好的，谢谢你，凯特。我爱你。我稍后再给你打。贱人星球永存。贱人星球。呜呼。拜拜。她说贱人星球永存。太棒了。她不知道我们的另一个。是的，她不认识蒂姆。所以她不知道是生日派对。好吧，所以我们有什么？各位，我们有小孩子的生日派对，还有我们的关系。策划师和客户？是的。对，派对策划师和客户。
Yeah, yeah. Perfect. Okay. Kids' birthday party, party planner and client. We're going to start. Yay. And I said decorator. Oh, she did say decorator.
对，对。完美。好吧。小孩子的生日派对，派对策划师和客户。我们要开始了。耶。我说的是装饰师。哦，她确实说了装饰师。
Oh, we're already not good at listening. This is not good. Decorator and client. kids' birthday party. Yes. Oh, thank God, Marcus, you're listening. All right. Should we begin?
哦，我们已经很不擅长倾听了。这可不妙。装饰师和客户。小孩子的生日派对。是的。谢天谢地，马库斯，你在听。好吧。我们开始吧？
And Sam, maybe as we go through scenes, you can give us a little, like, music, jege to, like, set the vibe. All right, here we go. And begin. And begin. Okay, if you'd like to go ahead and just, you know, bring your card in here, I think if you want to set it in the living room, that'll be totally fine. We've got a little time before people are getting here. First of all, I am the decorator. I will tell you where my cart goes. I don't want to come off as overly forceful, but I have been doing this for quite some time, and I know what kids
萨姆，也许在我们演场景的时候，你可以给我们放一点，比如，音乐，来设定一下氛围。好了，我们开始。开始。开始。好的，如果你愿意直接把你的小推车拉进来，我想如果你把它放在客厅里，那就完全没问题了。在大家来之前我们还有点时间。首先，我是装饰师。我会告诉你我的小推车该放哪儿。我不想显得过于强势，但我干这行已经有一段时间了，我知道孩子们想要什么。所以，如果你不介意往后退一点，我自己来就行。
want. So just, if you don't mind just backing up a little, I'll just do my thing. Okay. Miles, you know, I'm happy to have you here. It really seems like you think I'm going to try to step in your lane, but I'm just happy that you're here. I'm going to let you do your thing. Okay.
迈克尔，你知道的，我很高兴你能来。看起来你好像觉得我要越界，但我只是很高兴你能来。我会让你发挥的。好吧。
Dad, where's my Barbie cart? Oh, honey, I think that's over in the, I think it was in the kitchen, the last that I saw. Okay. I just thought there could be a little more pink. I just, this is just one shade of pink, and I was kind of hoping for more shades. Yes, more shades. I know the one, you know, I should have known that.
爸爸，我的芭比购物车在哪儿？哦，亲爱的，我想那在，我想我最后看到它时在厨房里。好吧。我只是觉得粉红色可以再多一点。我只是，这只有一种粉红色，我原本希望有更多种色调。是的，更多的色调。我知道那种，你知道的，我早该知道了。
You know what? I'm sorry, I'm getting a text. One second. Oh, go ahead. Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm. Oh, okay. Sorry, you were saying? Oh, no, I was just agreeing with what you were, what you wanted to do. More shades of pink. I think I can get that through. Okay. You know, listen, I will work on the shades of pink. You know, I'm not inflexible. I will work on that. But is there a way we can change the name on the? cake.
你知道吗？对不起，我收到一条短信。等一下。哦，请便。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。嗯哼。哦，好吧。对不起，你刚才说什么？哦，不，我只是同意你的看法，你想要怎么做。更多的粉红色。我想我可以做到这一点。好吧。你知道，听着，我会处理粉红色的色调的。你知道，我并不是不知变通。我会处理的。但是有没有办法改一下上面的名字？蛋糕。
Esmeralda is not fitting on the cake. And that I was going to bring that up. Does she have a nickname? She's got, I mean, she's got plenty of nicknames, a sport, tire kicker, my little gal. We cut to Esmeralda getting her cake. Dad, why the fuck does it say mesdural? Okay, so that's on me. I sort of caved pretty hard to Miles here at the party planner, the decorator, excuse me, sir.
“埃斯梅拉达”在蛋糕上写不下。我正要提这个。她有小名吗？她有很多小名，比如运动健将，踢轮胎者，我的小宝贝。我们切换到埃斯梅拉达拿到她的蛋糕。爸爸，这他妈的上面怎么写的是“美斯杜拉”？好吧，那是我的错。我在派对策划师、装饰师迈尔斯这里妥协得有点厉害，对不起，先生。
I'm sorry, honey No one is going to know It's for me I was talking with the other girls And we're thinking about leaving What? Dad, it's because no one calls me Messerailda. Okay, honey, I'm so sorry Okay, I know... This is so embarrassing.
我很抱歉，亲爱的，没人会知道的。这是给我的。我刚才和另外几个女孩聊天，我们正在考虑离开。什么？爸爸，那是因为根本没人叫我美斯杜拉。好吧，亲爱的，我真的很抱歉。好吧，我知道……这太尴尬了。
Katie, Katie. I am the coolest girl of the group You have a lot of influence. I am the coolest girl of the group. She really is. And like that, I can clear out this party. Just so everyone knows, she just did a little snap and a pose. Please don't make me get the snap, okay?
凯蒂，凯蒂。我是这群人里最酷的女孩。你很有影响力。我是这群人里最酷的女孩。她真的是。就这样，我可以把这个派对清场。为了让大家知道，她刚刚做了一个小小的响指和摆姿势。请不要逼我打响指，好吗？
You can't come back from the snap. Okay, please, don't snap at my daughter. We're going to make this right. Okay, Miles, is there anything? Can you redo the cake right now? Could you just make it bigger, Miles? Why can't it be like a 9 by 13? I don't understand.
你可承受不起打响指的后果。好吧，请不要对我女儿打响指。我们会把事情处理好的。好吧，迈尔斯，有什么办法吗？你能现在重新做一个蛋糕吗？你能不能把它做大一点，迈尔斯？为什么不能做成9乘13英寸的？我不明白。
Little is in. Everything is small. You not notice that everything I put in here is small, small balloons over there. Uh-huh. Small seats. No one can fit in them. I feel like I'm really between a rock and three hard, places right now where I've got Katie Esmeralda and Miles just all over me. So my daughter's whole
小才是王道。一切都很小。你没发现我这里放的所有东西都很小吗，那边有小气球。嗯哼。小座位。谁也坐不下。我觉得我现在真是进退维谷，卡蒂·埃斯梅拉达和迈尔斯都缠着我。所以，我女儿整个
social group is writing on this. Yeah, Miles, Little was in last week. See? Oh, you, you were Frank's daughter, aren't you? Yes. Oh, yes. I didn't know who you were going to be here. Otherwise, I would have brought out the good decorations. I, you know, I reserved them for VIP. Good decorations. I paid for the premium package, Miles. Premium regular person. Premium VIP is something completely different. Completely different. We cut to Miles' decorating office where he's got tiers of who and what is important. So I'm trying to wrap my head around this. Miles, there's sort of a secret tier that you don't tell a client about?
社交圈都指望这个了。是的，迈尔斯，小号上周才流行过。看到了吗？哦，你，你是弗兰克的女儿，对吧？是的。哦，是的。我不知道你会来这里。否则我会把高级装饰拿出来了。我，你知道的，我把它们留给VIP了。高级装饰。我付了高级套餐的钱，迈尔斯。高级是普通人。高级VIP完全是另一回事。完全不同。我们切换到迈尔斯的装饰办公室，那里分着谁重要、什么重要的等级。所以我正在努力理解这一点。迈尔斯，有一个你不会告诉客户的秘密等级？
Yes, that's right. Are you, I just need to do a little background check on you before I can reveree. all of what we can or cannot do. A background check? Yes. Miles, darling, we've done it on him. Here's the paperwork, darling. Oh, okay. Thank you.
是的，没错。你，在我能彻底决定我们能做什么或不能做什么之前，我只需要对你进行一下背景调查。背景调查？是的。亲爱的迈尔斯，我们已经对他做过调查了。文件在这里，亲爱的。哦，好的。谢谢。
Oh, you are a gym. Yes. Well, you know, here for your service, darling. Thank you, Christina. Miles, you look so fit. Looking so fit today. I have been in the gym. Oh, well, I can tell.
哦，你身材保持得真好。是的。嗯，你知道的，随时为您服务，亲爱的。谢谢，克里斯蒂娜。迈尔斯，你看上去真苗条。今天看起来真苗条。我一直在健身房锻炼。哦，嗯，我看得出来。
Swimming mostly, that's hard. Oh, well, that works out the whole body, doesn't it? It does. That's sort of a vibe here. I'll ignore it. Oh, yes. Sorry. Oh, that's okay.
主要是游泳，那挺难的。哦，嗯，那能锻炼全身，对吧？确实如此。这算是一种这里的氛围。我忽略它。哦，是的。抱歉。哦，没关系。
Okay, yes. 770 credit score. Very nice. 70 credit score. 770. 770. Okay, not bad. So you're running a background check and a credit score.
好吧，是的。770分信用评分。非常好。70分信用评分。770。770。好吧，还不错。所以你在做背景调查和信用评分。
That's a lot of it. Last page is the police report. Oh. Oh. Oh. Okay. You know, you can look at this shelf here. This little... Okay, the shelf says a duds on it.
这占了很大一部分。最后一页是警察报告。哦。哦。哦。好吧。你知道的，你可以看看这个架子。这个小……好吧，架子上写着“杂物”。
Yeah. Oh, I'm still deciding on what party I want. Sorry, I've been looking at the dubs shell for a while. Oh, no, that's okay. Yeah, nice to meet you. My name's Sandy. Hi, Sandy. I assume that you also had all these reports run on you and it didn't go well. Oh, I mean, I don't.
是的。哦，我还在决定我想要什么样的派对。抱歉，我盯着杂物架看了一会儿。哦，不，没关系。很高兴认识你。我叫桑迪。嗨，桑迪。我猜你也让人做了所有这些报告，结果不太好吧。哦，我的意思是，我没有。
think this shelf is great. I'm just having a party for my alligator. Oh, okay. Congratulations. That sounds really nice. Is it, is it the birthday of the alligator? Oh, just a typical Sunday alligator party. Should point out the alligator is no longer living. Yeah, I had it stopped years ago. Oh, okay. But the name Alligator Funeral. We didn't want to call it that. It's so a drag. Celebration of life, isn't it? Isn't it? Celebration of Life, right? That's the DUDD level. Okay. We cut to the Celebration of Life for the Alligator.
觉得这个架子很棒。我只是在为我的短吻鳄举办派对。哦，好吧。恭喜。听起来真不错。是，是短吻鳄的生日吗？哦，只是一个典型的星期日短吻鳄派对。应该指出的是，这只短吻鳄已经不在了。是的，我几年前把它做成标本了。哦，好吧。但名字叫短吻鳄葬礼。我们不想那样叫它。太扫兴了。生命庆典，对吧？对吧？生命庆典，对吧？那是“杂物”级别的。好吧。我们切换到短吻鳄的生命庆典。
Thank you for all coming today. As you know, Scaly and I were palsed for many, many years. Yeah, yes. Until the tractor accident. Oh, gosh. Oh, yeah. And, you know, but we have Scaly here stuffed and dressed like The It Clown, thanks to Miles.
谢谢大家今天能来。如你们所知，斯凯利和我做了很多很多年的好朋友。是的，是的。直到那场拖拉机事故。哦，天哪。哦，是的。而且，你知道的，但在迈尔斯的帮助下，我们把斯凯利做成标本并打扮成了“小丑回魂”里的样子。
Miles, you are a genius, and you should get all the awards they have in the entire world. Thank you, ladies. I'm really sensing a vibe from you and Miles here. I don't know if anyone else is picking up on that. I just see an artist. When I see an artist, I call it out, even if I'm out in the world, you know. Okay. That's what I do.
迈尔斯，你是个天才，你应该获得全世界所有的奖项。谢谢你们，女士们。我真的能感觉到你和迈尔斯之间有一种氛围。我不知道其他人有没有注意到这一点。我只看到一个艺术家。当我看到艺术家时，我就会指出来，即使我在社交场合也是如此，你知道的。好吧。这就是我的做法。
I'm in charge of the neighborhood watch. I call out beauty when I see it. That's right. Thank you, Michelle. I've done my absolute best to make Scaly the alligator that he was, the one that we remember. How did you get his lips to roll back? So his teeth show, that is just phenomenal. Well, it's a little helium insert.
我是社区巡逻队的负责人。当我看到美时，我就会指出来。没错。谢谢你，米歇尔。我一直在尽最大努力让斯凯利这条短吻鳄保持它生前的样子，也就是我们记忆中的那个样子。你是怎么让它的嘴唇往后卷的？这样它的牙齿就能露出来，这简直太神了。哦，那是一个微型氦气植入物。
You injected helium in his lips. That makes sense. The lips have like a floaty quality too. Yeah. Yes. That is just pure genius right there. I'm going to take that. I'm going to use it someday.
你在它的嘴唇里注射了氦气。这就说得通了。嘴唇也有那种漂浮的质感。是的。这简直就是纯粹的天才。我要把它学下来。我以后会用的。
I don't know how. But I'm following it back in my brain. If I'm being honest, I've been thinking about getting the lip fillers. Now I'm thinking I want the helium filler. Oh, yeah. I could see that on you. I think it would be good, right? I could totally see that on you.
我不知道怎么用。但我正在脑子里琢磨它。说实话，我一直在考虑做唇部填充。现在我想要氦气填充了。哦，是的。我能想象你做那个的样子。我想效果会不错，对吧？我完全能想象你做那个的样子。
Always showing off the teeth. There's got to be. some way that this could benefit the neighborhood watch. Oh, we've got lots of ladies that have no upper lip left anymore. You know what happens how you just get that thin line. It happens.
总是露出牙齿。总得有某种。办法能让社区巡逻队受益。哦，我们有很多女士上嘴唇都没了。你知道那种只剩下一条薄线的情况是怎么回事吗？这种情况会发生。
It happens. It happened to me. It's hard to take it seriously. It is. Well, no one can see your teeth for one. So that's awkward. I think there's something about seeing people's teeth. It's primal. Mm-hmm. Right?
这种情况会发生。我也有过。这让人很难严肃对待。确实。好吧，首先没有人能看到你的牙齿。所以这就很尴尬。我觉得看到人们的牙齿有一种奇妙之处。这是很原始的。嗯哼。对吧？
Yeah. You've got to show your teeth or people think something's up with you. Yeah. And I need to be trusted as head of the neighborhood walk. Whether you got good teeth, bad teeth, or none at all, you've got to be able to see them. That's right. Even if it's more in gummy, then tooth. You can't trust a person unless you see their teeth.
是的。你必须露出牙齿，否则人们会觉得你有什么不对劲。是的。而作为社区巡逻队的负责人，我需要被人信任。不管你牙齿好、牙齿坏还是干脆没有牙齿，别人都得能看见它们。没错。哪怕牙龈比牙齿多也一样。除非你能看到一个人的牙齿，否则你无法信任他。
Thank you, Maas. Thank you. Do you have a little helium? Can you hook a couple gals out? It hasn't been approved for human testing yet. It's animals and the animal was dead. Okay. We cut to a doctor's office.
谢谢你，马斯。谢谢。你有一点氦气吗？能不能帮几个大姐一把？这还没有获准进行人体测试。这是用于动物的，而且那只动物已经死了。好吧。我们切换到医生办公室。
I said I just wanted helium in my upper lip, and now I can't eat or swallow anything. Well, man, what possessed you to think that helium should be injected directly into your lips? Now, that just sounds like an accident waiting to happen. When you say it out loud like that, it doesn't sound so smart, but I was at this celebration of life for an alligator. And there was this very beautiful man named Miles, and he told me that helium in my lips could show my teeth. Well, ma'am, listen, we're going to get you some kind of treatment, but we have different tiers of treatment,
我说我只是想在我的上嘴唇里注入氦气，现在我什么也吃不下、咽不下去了。好吧，女士，是什么让你觉得应该把氦气直接注射进你的嘴唇里？这听起来就像是一场蓄势待发的事故。当你大声说出来时，听起来确实不太聪明，但我当时在参加一个短吻鳄的生命庆典。那里有一个非常漂亮的男人叫迈尔斯，他告诉我嘴唇里注入氦气可以显露出我的牙齿。好吧，女士，听着，我们会为你提供某种治疗，但我们有不同等级的治疗方案。
and we're going to have to do a quick little background check just to see which... I have the paperwork right here. Oh, wonderful. Credit score and everything. Credit score. What does I have to do with my upper lip? Oh, what is that, a four? 30?
我们得快速做个小背景调查，看看……我这里有文书工作。哦，太棒了。信用评分以及其他一切。信用评分？这跟我的上嘴唇有什么关系？哦，那是多少，4分？30？
My goodness. There's a shelf over there. If you just go look at that shelf. It's on the ground. Yes. It's just a bunch of rusty scalples. Yes. Oh.
天哪。那边有个架子。如果你去看那个架子的话。它在地上。是的。那只是一堆生锈的手术刀。是的。哦。
We're going to be able to just poke a little hole in there. And then there's, I think there's a bottle of alcohol or peroxide down there. That should clean everything out. That's all we can do for you. But thank you so much. much. Tell a friend. Going to get a scalpel.
我们可以在那里戳个小洞。然后，我想那边有一瓶酒精或双氧水。那应该能把所有东西都清理干净。这就是我们能为你做的全部了。但非常非常感谢。告诉你的朋友。去拿一把手术刀。
We cut a Michelle to a more of a holistic doctor's office. Michelle, I just want to say, I'm so sorry for what you experienced at the regular doctor's office the other day, trying to fix your ailment. So, so much. You're absolutely so welcome. I just want you to know that we also are ready to help you and treat you here. at Holly's holistic office. How long so I have to hold the crystal?
我们将米歇尔的场景切到一个更偏向全科的医生办公室。米歇尔，我只是想说，对于你前几天在普通诊所试图治疗病情时的遭遇，我感到非常抱歉。非常非常抱歉。不用谢，真的不用谢。我只是想让你知道，我们霍莉全科诊所也随时准备为你提供帮助和治疗。我得拿着这块水晶多久？
You're going to have to hold the crystal for about two weeks. Yes, yes. And that crystal you have there, you'll see it's sort of like an amethyst. I hope I'm pronouncing that right. That is based on a police report and a credit check that we ran on you. Seriously? Yes. Amethyst?
你大概得拿着这块水晶两周。是的，是的。你手里拿的那块水晶，你会发现它有点像紫水晶。希望我没发错音。这是根据我们对你进行的警方记录和信用调查决定的。真的吗？是的。紫水晶？
Yeah. If not that. that we would have given you just such a big, beautiful crystal with other properties. But this is, unfortunately, all we were able to provide for you today. I understand. Thank you so much. You're so welcome. Normally, this goes over so poorly with our clients, but I'm just so pleased at your positive attitude.
对。如果不是因为那些，我们本会送你一块那么大、那么漂亮、带有其他特性的水晶。但遗憾的是，这就是我们今天能为你提供的全部了。我明白。非常感谢。不用谢。通常情况下，我们的客户对这个反应很差，但我对你的积极态度感到非常高兴。
And I feel like this is the sort of thing I would love to have from most of our clients here. There's this lovely attitude, this vibe that you're bringing in. I just appreciate that you gave me some water because I was so thirsty. Water is definitely not in your tear. I am so sorry. Just consider yourself lucky because, you know, water, what is it anyway? I'm looking at my assistant here to see if they could tell me. I'm just here to spread good vibes.
我觉得这就是我希望从我们大多数客户身上看到的。这种可爱的态度，你带来的这种氛围。我很感激你给我一些水，因为我太渴了。水绝对不在你的排班里。非常抱歉。就当自己走运吧，因为，你知道的，水到底算什么？我正看着我的助手，看他们能不能告诉我。我来这里只是为了传播好氛围。
That's all I'm doing over here. And the vibes are right, so. I'm not so sensitive. If you didn't have anything, I can take a sip off. We cut Michelle to a Sunday church service where prayer requests are. being given it. And yet, I believe you were about to say something, I'm sorry, or should I go ahead? No, it's, it's okay.
我在这里做的就只有这些。而且氛围很对，所以。我没那么敏感。如果你没有什么东西，我可以抿一小口。我们将米歇尔的场景切到一个正在进行代祷请求的周日教堂礼拜。等等，我想你刚才要说什么来着，对不起，还是我先说？不，没，没关系。
We have, we have two pastors at this church, and we can, we can share it, we can share the love. Amen! Yes, just as our Lord would want us to do. So please, we'll, well, one sentence at a time, okay? After you, Diana. All right. Hello, everyone.
我们，我们这个教堂有两个牧师，我们可以，我们可以分享，我们可以分享爱。阿门！是的，正如我们的主所希望我们做的那样。所以请，我们，一次说一句，好吗？你先请，戴安娜。好的。大家好。
Welcome to Sunday Church. Woo! Woo! Woo! We're getting ready for some prayer requests. And we've got one here coming from, I believe this is directed from Clark, a neighbor of one, Michelle. Michelle, hello, we see you in the audience.
欢迎来到周日礼拜。呜！呜！呜！我们正准备接收一些代祷请求。我们这里收到一个，我想这是来自克拉克，邻居兼其中一个，米歇尔。米歇尔，你好，我们在观众席看到你了。
Hello, those. Hi, looking, Michelle. Doing great, Michelle. We see Michelle has deteriorated even more from the holistic office. Yes. And we have a prayer request that Michelle can get the care she needs, Diana. Yes, yes. Can we give her the care that she needs?
你好，那些。嗨，看起来，米歇尔。过得很好，米歇尔。我们看到米歇尔从全科诊所出来后情况恶化得更厉害了。是的。我们有一个代祷请求，希望米歇尔能得到她需要的照顾，戴安娜。是的，是的。我们能给她她需要的照顾吗？
No. Unfortunately no. Not. Her credit score and police report, we looked over it and we think God says you got to wait just a little longer. And, you know, normally we would make an exception for these documents not being in line. We also have a report card from her third grade teacher, and it's all check minuses. Yeah. People of the whole bitch. And Michelle, at this point, I don't know what you're saying.
不能。不幸的是，不能。不行。她的信用评分和警察报告，我们看过了，我们认为上帝说你还得再等一会儿。而且，通常情况下，如果这些文件不合格，我们会做个特例。我们还有她三年级老师的成绩单，全都是打勾加减号。是的。全体民众的。米歇尔，到了这一步，我不知道你在说什么。
Yeah, Michelle, we really want to help you. I do believe through the power of faith that I am going to understand. So I'm going to keep trying. We cut back to the birthday party. Dad, why is Aunt Michelle here? She is such a downer. Esmeralda, she had nowhere to go. Even the church wouldn't help her out.
是的，米歇尔，我们真的很想帮妳。我相信凭借信仰的力量，我一定能听懂。所以我会继续努力。我们切回生日派对。爸爸，为什么米歇尔阿姨会在这里？她真是个扫兴的人。埃斯梅拉达，她无处可去。连教堂都不肯帮她。
They wouldn't even accept a prayer request for her. I know. So she's just going to be sitting in the chair. Miles, please. Can you do something? She's going to just ruin the party. She is throwing off. the feng shui in here with those lips.
他们甚至不肯接受她的代祷请求。我知道。所以她只能一直坐在椅子上。迈尔斯，求你了。你能做点什么吗？她会毁了派对的。她用那种嘴唇把这里的风水都搞坏了。
They're so swollen. And, Ezzie, if she sits in that chair, I am going to snap and pose. Don't snap. I'm going to snap and pose. Katie, please, if I could, if there are anything I could do for you or your father, please don't snap. This is my daughter's birthday. Everything's writing on this.
它们肿得太厉害了。而且，埃齐，如果她坐在那张椅子上，我真的要崩溃了并摆造型。别崩溃。我要崩溃并摆造型。凯蒂，求你了，如果我可以，如果有什么我可以为你或你父亲做的，请别崩溃。这是我女儿的生日。一切都押在这上面了。
Okay. Let me get in there. I'm Miles. There's no challenge that I cannot rise to. Someone get me a piece of fabric. I'm going to just wrap her. Some lipstick, we can just put a little red on there or pink, more pink. Here's a carpet swatcher that I had from a carpet we were sampling.
好吧。让我上。我是迈尔斯。没有什么挑战是我无法应对的。谁给我拿块布来。我只要把她裹起来。有些口红，我们可以在上面涂一点红色或粉色，更粉一点。这里有一块地毯样品，是我从我们抽样的地毯里拿到的。
Go ahead. Okay. Scissors. I can do something with that. Ships, sip, sip, sip, snip. Michelle. Okay. Just don't move.
来吧。好的。剪刀。我能用它做点什么。剪，剪，剪，剪，剪。米歇尔。好了。别动。
What did she say? Does anybody know what she's saying at this morning? I don't know what she's saying. What? I'm not liking this. Miles, I'm getting the sense that you think Michelle is trying to cramp your style, and I can assure you she's just looking for help. I'm just going to wrap this.
她刚才说什么？有人知道她今天早上在说什么吗？我不知道她在说什么。什么？我不喜欢这样。迈尔斯，我感觉你认为米歇尔是在故意妨碍你出风头，但我向你保证，她只是在寻求帮助。我来把这个缠上。
Oh, this is kind of cute. If I do that, it's kind of like a cake topper. The lips are kind of like a cake topper, a big kissy face, you know, and biting. If you just sit here next to the cake, there's your other. shade of pink, and boom, that's somewhat attractive. Happy birthday, happy birthday, Esmeralda, happy birthday. And we fade to blast. You guys, that was our improv show.
哦，这个挺可爱的。如果我这样做，它有点像个蛋糕装饰。嘴唇有点像蛋糕装饰，一个大大的亲亲脸，你知道的，咬着。如果你就坐在蛋糕旁边，这是你的另一种粉红色，轰，这就有点吸引人了。生日快乐，生日快乐，埃斯梅拉达，生日快乐。然后我们渐隐淡出。各位，那是我们的即兴表演秀。
I had a blast. I hadn't done this in a really long time. It was really fun, and you guys are so good. Yes. That was so much fun. All the moves that were being. made and just the communication from just a look across a table. There was some social commentary in there as well.
我玩得太开心了。我真的很久没做过这个了。真的很有趣，而且你们都太棒了。是的。太有趣了。所有的动作，还有仅仅通过跨过桌子的一眼进行的交流。里面也有一些社会评论。
A little bit, you know, the tears. There was layers. Yes. Yeah. And I'm so sorry, I broke a few times, but there's just so funny stuff. That's having fun. Usually when I would break on stage, I would go look in a cabinet. That was like my, like, as I started to laugh, I'm like, oh, something over here, something
有一点，你知道的，眼泪。很有层次感。是的。是的。我很抱歉，我笑场了好几次，但里面真的有很多搞笑的东西。这就是在玩乐。通常我在台上笑场时，我会去看一个柜子。那就像我的，当我开始笑时，我就想，哦，这边的某个东西，某个
over, looked through a drawer, like, turned my back to stay. stage. That's a pro level tip for improvisers. Take that. Look into a cabinet. Was it always like very strict like do not break or? No, no. We just tried not to. But you know, I mean, when you're on stage with people who you just respect and they make you laugh so hard, it's inevitable. I would try to let myself have a little more freedom if I'm maybe on the backline. Yeah. Not in a scene to react to something, but even sometimes in a scene like I probably, I think I did today just cackle because of something one of you said. Same, same. Well, that wraps up our show for today. And Jenna is back. Hey, lady. Hi there. Oh, I just loved this episode. Thank you guys for putting this together.
那边的东西，透过抽屉看，就像，把背转过去面对舞台。这是即兴表演者的专业级技巧。收下吧。看着柜子。是不是一直都要求非常严格，绝对不能笑场？不，不。我们只是尽量不笑。但是你知道，我的意思是，当你和那些你非常尊重、能让你笑得死去活来的人同台时，这是难免的。如果我可能在后排的话，我会尽量让自己多一点自由。是的。不是在场景中对某事做出反应，但有时甚至在场景中，就像我今天可能做的，因为你们谁说的话而咯咯大笑。一样，一样。好了，我们今天的节目就到这里。珍娜回来了。嗨，美女。大家好。哦，我太喜欢这一集了。谢谢你们把这个拼凑起来。
I loved hearing you both do improv. I listened to it one morning because, you know, and I miss you guys. So I was really excited to hear your voices, and I was listening while I had my morning coffee. And ladies, I literally spit out my coffee during the callback to the awful credit score at the church. I just loved that not even the church would help you because of your low credit score. That was a funny runner. The whole thing. I mean, it was great. And Sam, your sound design on that was chef's kiss.
我喜欢听你们两个做即兴表演。我有一天早上听了，因为，你知道的，我想念你们。所以我真的很兴奋能听到你们的声音，我在喝早茶的时候听的。女士们，在回应教堂那可怕的信用评分的那个包袱时，我真的把咖啡喷出来了。我太喜欢了，连教堂都不帮你，因为你的信用评分低。那真是一个有趣的贯口包袱。整段都是。我的意思是，太棒了。萨姆，你在这上面的音效设计简直是神来之笔。
perfect. I also want to say a big thank you to Michael Norton for sharing with us about his time on the office. I am sorry that I miss getting to reconnect with him. He'll just have to come back. He can come back. He could come do a Friday chit-chat. He sure could. And I also just want to give a special thank you to my friends and improvisers Connor McCabe and Marcus Fulmer for coming in and doing some improv with us. Yes, you guys. Thank you so much. And we also want to give a shout out and thank you to Kate Lannery and Tim Newman for answering their phones when we called them and giving us those great suggestions. And thank you guys so much for listening. We hope you enjoyed Michael's Improv class,
完美。我还要特别感谢迈克尔·诺顿与我们分享他在办公室的时光。很遗憾我错过了与他重新联系的机会。他以后还得回来。他可以回来。他可以来参加周五闲聊。他当然可以。我还想特别感谢我的朋友兼即兴表演者康纳·麦凯布和马库斯·福尔默来和我们一起做即兴表演。是的，伙计们。非常感谢你们。我们还要向凯特·兰内里和蒂姆·纽曼大声致谢，感谢他们在我们打电话时接听并给我们提供了那些绝佳的建议。非常感谢大家收听。希望你们喜欢迈克尔的即兴表演课，
and we'll see you next week. Yes, we will see you next week. And listen, if you're going to be in Chicago between now and October 19th, will you please come see my play, Ashland Avenue at the Goodman Theater? We really will have to close as of October 19th. They're putting something else in the theater. So we will get kicked out. This is our final extension. But, guys, this is it the last couple of weeks. Go see it. Guys, you're going to love it. And I'm going to just tell you where I'm going to be real fast. Josh and I's cookbook, as you know, comes out October 21st. You can pre-order now. We really want to get on that New York Times bestseller list. And I guess that's the way you do it. But we're coming to a few cities. We are going to be in Ridgewood, New Jersey,
我们下周见。是的，我们下周见。听着，如果你从现在到10月19日之间要去芝加哥，能不能来看我的话剧，古德曼剧院的《阿什兰大道》？我们真的要在10月19日闭幕了。他们在剧院里安排了别的东西。所以我们要被踢出去了。这是我们的最后一次延期。但是，伙计们，这是最后几个星期了。去看吧。伙计们，你们会喜欢的。我快快地告诉大家我要去哪里。如你们所知，乔希和我的食谱将于10月21日出版。你现在可以预订了。我们真的很想登上《纽约时报》畅销书排行榜。我想这就是方法。我们要去几个城市。我们要去新泽西州里奇伍德，
October 21st at Bookends Bookstore. I'll put this in our stories. We're also October 23rd, going to be in Dallas, Texas, at Interabang Books, and October 26 at Diesel Bookstore in Santa Monica. We'd love to meet you and chat, and I'll put all that in stories. Thanks, you guys. Lady, I can't believe that literally, like, the day I'm flying home is the day you're flying off to do all your book stuff. And I'm going to have to wait another week before I get to see you in person. I know, I know. We need some real BFF time, lady. We do.
10月21日在Bookends书店。我会把这个发到我的快拍里。我们还将在10月23日去德克萨斯州达拉斯的Interabang书店，10月26日去圣莫尼卡的Diesel书店。我们很想见到你们并聊聊天，我会把这一切都发到快拍里。谢谢你们，伙计们。美女，我真不敢相信，字面意思，我飞回家的那天竟然就是你飞去搞你那些书的事情的日子。我得再等一个星期才能见到你真人。我知道，我知道。我们需要一些真正的闺蜜时间，美女。我们确实需要。
All right, guys. Thank you so much for listening. We'll see you next week. See ya. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer and our associate producer
好了，伙计们。非常感谢你们的收听。我们下周见。再见。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》是奥德赛（Audyssey）的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的执行制作人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·基弗，我们的副制作人
is Ainsley Bubicoe. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz. Our theme song is Ruppertree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
是阿因斯利·布比科。奥德赛的执行制作人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。《办公室女士》由比尔·舒尔茨混音和母带制作。我们的主题曲是克里·布拉顿的《Ruppertree》。这集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。